Welcome to this tutorial where we're going
to be building an e commerce website using
Django. To get started, we can just clone
this Django project boilerplate repository
that we have on GitHub. So you can just copy
this link. And we're going to clone it here.
And so with that, we can then change into
that repository. And I'm going to open it
up in Visual Studio code. And so we can then
create ourselves a virtual environment are
then activated. And we're just going to go
here into the requirements. And I'm going
to change this to Django 2.2 that we're going
to install. We can then type pip install,
dash our requirements dot txt. And with that
installed, we can then get started. Hey, everyone,
before we jump into this, if you're interested
in becoming a better Django developer, then
check out just django.com. Enroll and you'll
get access to exclusive video courses every
month on Python, JavaScript, and react with
a specific focus on obviously Django. The
link is in the description below. So now that
everything is installed, we can make use of
this management command that we have in our
core app. And that's the Rename command, which
allows us to rename the project. So all we
need to do is just called Python managed.py
rename, and I'm gonna call mine DJ ecommerce.
And now you can see it's been renamed to DJ
ecommerce. And there it is. And let's try
and run the server. And there we go. We can
see we have two unapplied migrations. And
that's because of moving over to Django 2.2.
So we can run Python, manage that py migrate.
And there we go. Now we can run the server
again, and cool. And we can go and open this
up in the browser as well. And okay, we get
this no such file, which is static in E and
V, that's a directory that we just need to
create for our static files. So just created
there. And if we try again, now we're just
getting the generic four, four, which is fine,
because we don't actually have any URLs. And
so before we start coding, I'm just going
to say that this tutorial is not for absolute
beginners, if you haven't worked with Jango,
before then rather watch some of the other
tutorials on this channel, before you jump
into this. And it is assumed that you have
an understanding of HTML, CSS, JavaScript,
and Django as well. So if you are not that
comfortable with all of those concepts, then
this is going to be difficult. And we're also
assuming that you've seen some of the other
tutorials on this channel where we've covered
things like authentication. And so if you
are not familiar with any of that, then again,
rather watch some of the other tutorials before
you look at this, because the pace will be
quite fast then. And otherwise, if you're
comfortable with all of that, then we can
actually get started here. So let's go and
search for Django, all auth, because that's
what we're going to use for authentication.
So we'll just go to the read the docs, and
we just need to install the package. So let's
come here, we'll stop the server, and just
type pip install Django, all auth then we
need to bring the authentication back end.
So inside DJ e commerce settings, we'll go
all the way to the bottom and add authentication,
then we need to go and add all of these installed
apps, so sites and all the all auth apps.
And we can do that here inside installed apps.
Hope paste them there. And then we can scroll
down, specify the site ID as one. And then
we need this URL pattern added into our URLs.
So we'll come and add it there. And I'm just
gonna change it to a path and remove that
regular expression. There we go. And then
it just says we need to migrate. So we'll
say Python, manage that py migrate. And cool.
There are all of those migrations now. And
we can go and run the server. Now and if we
take a look here, at account login, and we
have a login page, we should be able to log
in with an admin user. Cool. So I am, you
can just create your own admin user to login.
And so we were successfully logged in. So
that's the basic installation of Django all
auth we will look at styling this later on.
And so the next thing going to be creating
our models. So we're going to do this inside
core models. And this is going to be everything
that defines the logic of storing an order,
and the process of adding an item to an order.
And we've touched on this in the shopping
cart video that we did, which I'll link in
this video as well. So if you haven't seen
that we did introduce some of that logic here,
but we'll go through it again. So the basic
concept is that we have an order item. And
this comes from model stock model. And I'll
say pause for now. And then we have an order.
And this is so that we can link all of the
order items to that order. And the order,
you could basically view as the shopping cart.
So we store all of the items that the user
has added to the cart inside this order. And
every time they log in, we fetch the order
that they have, and display that order with
kind of like a shopping cart item count in
the top right corner, like you see in most
ecommerce websites, and will also define some
kind of Boolean field on the order to say
whether it has been ordered or not. So if
it's not ordered, then this will be the order
that is being used until it is ordered. And
as soon as it is ordered, then the next order
will be created after that. Now even though
we have an order item, we will still need
another class, which will be the item. And
so the order item is just a way of linking
between the order and the item itself. So
the item will be displayed in a list of items
that you can purchase. But as soon as you
add it to the cart, then it becomes an order
item. And this is kind of like an intermediate
step, a link between these two models. And
you can then handle very specific logic about
the order item here inside this class. So
let's just pass in some basic fields. For
now we'll add a character field to the item,
we'll just say maximum length is 100. And
then we'll define the string method and just
say return self dot title. And I'm just going
to copy that and paste it for both of these
as well, then we're going to need to make
use of our author user model. So that comes
from Django settings. So we'll say from Django,
dot con, input settings. And then we're going
to associate the order with a user. So user
equals models dot foreign key with settings
dot auth user model, and we'll say undelete
equals two models dot cascade, will add. And
ordered field which we can say is models,
dot Boolean field default, equals false. And
here I'll say return user dot user name as
the string representation. Then we'll also
specify the items as a many to many field.
And this is of the order item, so that we
can add these order items into the order.
And then we can also add something like a
start date. So the moment that the order was
created, and we can say this is a date time
field, and we'll pass in auto now add equal
to true. And then we could say, an ordered
date equals models that date time field. And
I'm not going to pass anything in. So we'll
manually set that value the moment that it
is ordered. And then here in the order item,
we can link that to this item model. So we'll
say the item equals models dot foreign key
with the item. And I'll also just specify
undelete as cascade, then here in the item
model, this is where we're going to define
the price. So this can just be a float field,
just like this. And then if we pull up in
a terminal, we can try and run the server.
Cool. So that's still working, we can then
try and make these migrations. So let's run,
make migrations. And then we will say migrate.
And we can also then go and add these into
the admin. So just say from dot models, import
item, or the item and order, and then call
admin dot site dot register. And we'll just
add these in. And now we can go into the views
and just create some basic views here. So
we'll say define, let's say the item list.
Just take send a request and say return render
of that request, which we can just go to item
list dot html. And we'll create some context
which we'll need to get those models. So say
from dot models, import item just for now.
And then we can say, this context has items,
which can just be item, dot objects, dot all.
And then we'll bring that into the core URLs.
So I'll say urls.pi. They're also from Django
dot URLs, import path, and then say our URL
patterns equals to a list. And we'll just
use an empty string. And then just say, from
dot views, import item list, and then we can
go into the DJ ecommerce URLs. And we already
importing include. So we'll create another
path that just goes to an empty string and
say, include core URLs. And also specify a
namespace as core. And then if we say run
the server, it says we need an app name. So
here in core URLs to say app name, equals
core, there we go. Then we can just go into
the templates and our create item, list dot
html, we'll say that it extends from base
dot html. And then we'll create a block content.
And inside here, we can just say, Here is
the list of items. And say, for item in items,
men and four. And I'll just, I'll just say
item, like this. And so now if we go to that
base URL, with these get that rendering out,
but we can also then go into the admin. And
we'll just create some items. There we go.
And there we can see them coming through.
Okay, cool. So everything is working so far.
And now what I'm going to do is go and grab
a template, which is the MD bootstrap ecommerce
template. So you can go to MD bootstrap, comm
slash freebies slash jQuery, slash ecommerce.
And I'll also link this in the description.
And here, you can download this for free,
which we're going to use in our project. It
has an MIT license, so we're going to make
use of this. And so that's just because one,
we don't want to spend time designing, because
that's not the point of Django. And two, it'll
look a lot nicer. And everyone likes to work
with something that looks nicer. So you can
go and download this for free. I already have
it. So I'm going to bring it into this project
now. Okay, so there we can see the project.
And basically, we want to take all of these
static files, bring them into our static in
Ian v folder, and then everything else we
can bring into the templates. And I'm pretty
much going to delete everything else that's
not an HTML page. So let's just grab all of
those folders, bring them into static. So
there they are. And then the checkout homepage
product page, I'm just going to bring into
the templates. And then we can get rid of
that. And so if we take a look at the homepage,
this is basically what our base dot html needs
to make use of. So what I'm going to do is
just go to the view here, and change this
to home page dot html. And then if we go back
here, and refresh this, we're not going to
get any styling. Sure. So let's go back. And
what we're going to do is just add in the
static reference here. So just start by saying
loads static. And then in these h refs, and
in all of these scripts here as well, and
then all the images are going to add that
static command. So for example, static like
this. Okay, let's try this again. And this
is what it looks like. Cool. And what's nice
about this, as well as that we get a little
bit of guidance as to what we need to make
work. And if you've watched the tutorial series
on how to build any blog, with Django, then
this is the same kind of concept. Once you've
been given a template, you just figure out
what needs to be rendered and what kind of
data needs to come through. So immediately,
just looking at some of these These items,
you've got a category sport where you've got
a title, gray blouse, you've got to kind of
tag here. So best seller, and you've got the
price. And that blue as well. If we inspect
that, you can see it says primary color, that's
why it's blue. So we could define also a label
color. And that way, then you can specify
that in the model. So that when you create
the item, then you could output whether it's
the primary color, or it's the secondary color,
etc. So that's some of the fields that we
could then define on this model, the item
model. And we also see some pagination here.
And if we scroll up, you've got some kind
of filters that you could filter by category,
a search bar, and you've got a cart item count.
So what I'm going to do to end off this video,
so the end of this video, what I'm going to
do is in these files, the checkout page, and
the product page, I'm going to make them extend
from a base dot html. And the base that HTML
is basically going to be kind of what we have
right now, it's just going to be the blocks.
And it's just going to make use of all the
scripts and the links that we have here in
this head. And so I'll show what this looks
like, when that's done. Okay, so now I finished
the templates. And this is what it looks like.
As per usual, we can go to the checkout page.
And this is what it looks like when you check
out. And this is what it looks like on kind
of like a product detail page, I would assume.
So now that we at least have something that
we can work with. In the next one, we can
start with the logic of adding to the cart
and removing items from the cart, and that
whole checkout process. So let's just start
by running the server, I have the virtual
environment already activated. And so this
is what it looks like. So let's just go down.
And we talked a little bit about these product
items in the last one, how we could take some
of the information we're seeing on this card
item and bring it as fields on the model.
So that's what we'll start off doing. We're
going to create a category. So you can see
like sportswear outwear shirt, and then we'll
create the label as well. So that's going
to give us this blue or red kind of label.
For more information about this specific item,
we already have the price and the title, we
can just go into core models, and take a look.
So there's title and price. So let's add these
ones in. We've got the category and then the
label. So what I'm going to do is just create
some category choices. And this is going to
be a tupple. And the first entry is what goes
in the database. And then the second entry
is what's displayed. So let's just take a
look here, there's Mike shirt, sportwear,
and outwear. So we'll just put them here.
So shirt, sportwear, and outway. And we'll
just put s, SW, and o w. And we'll just take
this here. And we'll say that the category
equals to a character field. And also that
the choices are the category choices. And
we'll say the maximum length equals two because
that's how many characters maximum length
is here. And then I'm going to copy that and
actually just copy the entire thing there
as well. And we're going to make this the
label choices. And then this will be the label.
And it will come from the label choices. And
if we just come back here and inspect this,
then you can see this is danger color. And
we could change that to primary color. Most
likely we could change this to secondary color.
So you can see all the different classes that
we can add. So that's just going to add three
for now. We'll add primary, secondary, and
actually we'll make this lowercase. And then
we'll add danger. So this could be p, s and
D, and also the maximum length is one. Cool.
So those are the fields then covered in terms
of these items as we can see so far. So if
we come back, we can make migrations. So let's
just run Python managed up py make migrations
up, we're not putting any commas anywhere.
So let's make sure this is a tupple. Try that
again. Okay, not saying we need to provide
one set of defaults, and that's correct. So
for the category, we can just say provide
default And I'll just say s for shirt. And
then for the label, we'll add a default and
say, p for primary, there we go. And we can
say migrate. And let's go and run the server.
And we can then go to the templates, go into
products dot html. And if we open this up,
and just come back here, we only need to grab
one of these cart items. And then we can just
loop through all of them, and just open up
home dot html. And there's still quite a lot
inside here. But if we just scroll down, after
the second and third slide, we could probably
remove those as well. And you've got controls.
And you've got categories. So that's four
filters. And then as we scroll down, then
we've got card content, and card image. So
this is one card, it's inside the grid column.
So if we come down, you can see that that's
what's repeating itself. So we can actually
close it on the dove on this column. And you've
got an entire row like that as well. So what
I'm going to do is actually just remove one
of these rows. And then if we go inside this
one, I'm going to delete those three columns
there. And I'm going to remove some of these
comments as well. So inside this row, I'm
going to loop through it. And we can go and
take a look at the view that we have for home
that HTML. So we can come here and add this
context in there as well. And then we can
loop through the items. So we'll say, for
item in items, and then just say in for then
inside this card, all replaced that number
with item dot price, then that is the title.
So item dot title, then you've got new there.
So this new as the label. So danger will replace
with the label display. And the way that we
get the display is by calling get then the
field name. So get underscore label underscore
display. So this will be item dot get label
display. And I'm just going to leave it as
new for now we'll figure out how we can change
that text later. And then this is the category.
So it's very similar to get labeled display.
This will be get category, display. And if
we take a look at this now, then there we
can see our two items coming through. And
what I'm going to do is actually just go back
here into the view. And I'm going to change
this into a class based view. If you haven't
seen our video on class based views, then
be sure to check it out, the link is going
to display over here in the top right corner.
And in that video, we cover everything about
class based views. So I'm going to make use
of them here, because they can help in making
us write a lot less code. So what I'm going
to do is just come here to the top, and we'll
say from Django dot views dot generic import
list view. And I'll import the detail view
as well. So the home view right now is kind
of like a list view, because we are listing
out these items. So what I'm going to do is
just come in here and we'll say, class, home
view, which inherits from the ListView. And
then we just have to specify the model, which
is the item, then I'll say that the template
name equals to home dot html. And if we then
take that home view, we can bring that in
here. And I'll replace it like this is not
as view. And everything is still working.
Now if we come back here, now they're not
displaying anymore. And that's because the
context variable is different. So if we come
back up top here, and we're we're looping
through the items, it's not items anymore,
this would be object list. There we go. Now
they're coming through. And then we can also
go into finer detail view. And I'm going to
get rid of this function based view there.
So I'll say class product, detail view. Or
rather, we can call it item detail view. And
that's going to inherit from the detail view,
say the model equals to item and the template
name is going to be equal to product, not
HTML. And that's basically this view here.
And if we just take a look at what that looks
like, you can see it's kind of like detail
view, even though these images have nothing
to do with this item here. I can imagine that
this is supposed to be kind of like a detail
view where you can add it to cart. So we'll
treat it like a detail view. And I'm going
to come into the templates and rename products
to product dot html. And then we can save
this here. And then inside the URLs, we can
bring that view. So item detail view, instead
of product. And then we'll make a product.
And I'm going to make it taken a slug, just
like that. And I'll change the name to product
there. And the reason this has to take in
a slug is because this is a detail view. So
either we pass in a primary key, or we pass
in a slug for the class based view to handle
which object it's getting. And so then here
inside product or HTML, we can just scroll
down a little bit. And this is the image there.
Then here, we have some categories. And I'm
gonna get rid of two of them there, because
we only have one. So this will then be object
dot get category display, where object is
the default template variable name. And if
we take a look here, that seems to be like
a previous price. So the $100 is a discount
price, which you could add in to the model
as well. But for now, what I'm going to do
is just replace the 100 with object price,
then here in home dot html, let's make sure
that we can actually redirect to the absolute
URL of each instance. And I'm just going to
do that here inside this href. So we can make
sure that here on this model, we have a get
absolute URL. So I'll just say define, get
absolute URL, which just takes itself. And
I'll just say that it returns a reverse, which
is going to need to be imported. So up here
at the top, we can say, from Django dot shortcuts,
import reverse. And we're going to reverse
to the core namespace. And let's just move
these files around. And then to the product
URL, like that. And we need to pass in keyword
arguments, where the slope will be self dot
slug. And that means we need to go and add
a slug field here. So we'll say slug equals
models dot slug field. And then we can say
Python managed.py make migrations, I'll provide
a default, and I'll just say, test product
like that, then we can go and migrate. And
I'll run the server. And then here, we need
to just go into the admin to fix those slugs.
So if we go to items, this can be test product
one. And then this can be tested product.
Two. Cool, so now we have that reverse working.
So we can take the get absolute URL and bring
that into the home dot html. and here we can
say item dot get absolute URL. And if we come
back here, then if I click on the title, then
it redirects us to that URL. And we can see
that the shirt tag is coming through even
though this isn't the shirt, and we've got
the $100 price there. And we also have a couple
other fields here, you've got a description,
and you've got kind of like a previous price,
or rather, this is the actual price. And this
is the discount price. So what we can do is
we can come here on the item. And we can say,
that's the price. And then we can say this
is the discount price. But we can say, blank
and no equal true so that you don't actually
have to have a discount price. And then we
can go and make migrations migrate, run the
server. And if we go into the admin again,
then let's go to these items. And I'll add
a discount price of 50 to that one, and I'll
keep the second one blank. So let's go back,
then here we want to display, then what we
want to do is we want to say if there is so
how we'll do this is we'll say if there is
a discount price, then show the discount price,
otherwise show the normal price. And then
if you click on that item, then here will
show this original price if there is the original
price, but only if there is a discount price.
So let's just come back here and in home dot
html. We'll create a little bit Have logic
here. So we'll say, if item dot discount price.
So if it has a discount price, then show the
discount price else will show the price, and
then just say endif. And we can kind of copy
that logic there. And let's just come back
to home. And now you can see that 50 is showing
me, which is the discount price. And let's
click on this item to go here. So then in
product HTML, I'm just gonna paste everything
here. So again, this will be if object that
discount price. So if there is a discount
price, then we're going to show all of that.
And the 200 is what's being scratched out.
So that is the price. And then we'll show
discount price next to it. Otherwise, we'll
just show object up price. And let's make
sure that this is inside a span as well. So
just like that, and then we can delete all
of those there. Now, if we come back, now
we can see that one there. But let's just
go back to home and see the second one. And
now you can see only the 200 is shown. And
let's actually also come back and add a description
on the item. So this is just going to be a
text field. Again, make migrations. default
is going to be this is a test description.
And just add some nonsense there. And then
we'll say migrate. Cool. So now we have that
field. And we also have the list view and
the detail view working. And let's actually
just go back here and add this href. And I'm
going to add it over this div there. And let's
just come back here to home. Now, if you click
on that item, then it redirects you as well.
Cool. So now let's look at how we can add
an item to the cart. So I'm just going to
close that there. And we're going to need
to create a function that can handle that.
So one function that will add an item to the
cart, which is basically just going to take
that item creates an order item, assign the
order item to the order, if the user has an
order, and if otherwise, then it will create
that order on the spot. And then when you
remove the item, then it's just going to remove
the order item from the items field. So we'll
just come here and define add to cart, which
is going to take a request and a slug. And
the slug is the slug of the item so we can
add that specific item. So let's say that
the item equals and we'll say import get object
or four, four, so we can use this method and
just pass in the item and say with a slug
equals to slug, then we need to see if the
user has an order or not. So let's just check
if we've imported it. So we'll need order
item and we'll need order. And then here,
we'll just say that the order item equals
to an order item, which will create. And we'll
just say that the item equals to this item
that we just got now. And then we need to
check if the user has an order. So if they
have an order, then we will basically just
modify the quantity of this item in the order.
And we don't have a Quantity field on the
item at the moment. So we can go and do that
now. We'll say quantity equals models dot
integer field. And we'll say default equals
one, so that when it's created, by default,
it's only one item. So let's make migrations,
and then migrate in run server. So here, we're
going to say that the order equals to order
dot objects dot filter, and then we'll filtered
based on the user. So we'll say where user
equals request dot user, and where is ordered
equals false. So or rather ordered. So this
is where we're making sure that we're only
getting the order that has not been completed
because they might have some orders that are
completed. So we need to make sure that we
pass this into this filter and if this order
query sets exists. So we'll say if order query
set dot exists, then we will grab the order
from this query set. So we'll say order equals
to order query set of zero. So then we need
to check if the order item is in the order.
So we'll say if order dot items dot filter,
where the item double underscore slug equals
to item dot slug, and we say if this exists,
then that means that this item is already
in the cart. And we can then just say that
order item, dot quantity, plus equals one,
and then say Order Item, dot save. And I'm
actually realizing now that this quantity
shouldn't be on the item, it should be on
the order item. Because here's where we want
to keep track of how many order items we have.
So let's just save that. And then let's make
migrations. And let's just see, okay, we have
to save this file. And basically just moving
that field, now we can run the server again.
So this is all if the order query said exists.
But if the order query does not exist, so
let's say else, then we will say order equals
to order that objects, not create where the
user equals request dot user. And then we
just say order dot items, dot add, and just
add that order item. And then after all of
that, then we can just say return redirect.
And I'm going to redirect us back to the slug
of the item that we just added. So this is
going to be we take a look at the URLs, this
is going to be product. So core product, and
then keyword arguments. Where slug is the
slug that was passed in. And then we'll just
import the redirect from Django dot shortcuts.
And everything seems fine. So now this add
to cart view, we need to bring into the URLs
as well. So we'll just bring it here. And
we'll add another path. And just say this
is add to cart, which is also going to take
in a slug. And then say add to cart and say
name equals Add To Cart as well. And then
we can take this name of the URL, come back
to the model. And we're going to create another
shortcut method here on the item. So we'll
say define, get, add to cart URL of self.
And we're going to basically return the exact
same thing here. But this is going to go to
Add To Cart view, and we just pass in the
slug as well, then we can use this in the
template. So if we go to the products dot
html, and also get rid of that description
there, because now we have our own ones, we
can say, object dot description. And here
we have the Add to Cart button. I'm going
to copy this button, paste it outside the
form. And I'm just going to comment out the
form for the time being, and I'll change this
to an a tag. And I'll say the H ref goes to
object, dot. And I'll just copy this to get
Add To Cart URL. And then I'm going to get
rid of the type Submit. So now if we refresh
this here, now if I click Add to cart, and
says order data can be null. That's right.
So this is the order date here on the order.
So that means that here when we create the
order, we just need to pass in the order date.
So I'm going to just specify that here. And
we're going to import from Django dot utils.
So Django dot utils, import timezone. And
then we can take this and say it equals to
timezone dot now, so it returns in a way or
naive day time, depending on the settings.
And this is okay for what we want to do. So
then we'll just pass this into this create
method, so order date equals to audit date.
And now let's just go back I'll refresh this
click Add to Cart. And it says Add To Cart
slug is not defined. And this is because we're
using a redirect not a reverse call here.
So let's just change this from keyword arguments
to slug, equals slug. And let's come back
and try that again. Cool. And let's also open
up the admin. So we can see, if we check the
order items. And it says, We're getting this
error there, that's from our defined string
method. Let's say return, we'll actually use
an F string here. And we'll say return self
dot item dot quantity. And I'll say of self
dot item, dot title, because the item has
a title. And this is meant to be self, not
quantity. And we've got a bunch of them from
pressing that button. So let's just go and
delete all of these. And it's come back and
say, add to cart. And then it redirects us
back to this page, which is fine. And now
we can see one of dummy item one with a quantity
of one. And let's go back to the order here.
The items not selected at the moment. And
that's because we probably didn't do that
here. And we didn't, so we checked if the
order item was in the order. So if it was,
then we just added one. But if it wasn't.
So else, then we need to say order dot items
dot add. And we're also adding the order item
in there. Cool. So let's go back and delete
that order item again. And then we'll say
add to cart, refresh this, there it is going
back to the order. And now we can see it's
added. And let's see what happens if I click
it again. And if we refresh here, then we
can see that there were two now. So let's
go back to the order items and see what's
happened is that we've actually created a
second one, and set the quantity to two, whereas
we would have actually wanted the original
one to have a quantity of two. So that means
we have something wrong here in this method.
And that's that we're creating the item every
single time regardless of whether it's in
the order or not. So one way we can control
this is by changing this into the get or create
method. And then here on the order item, we
could also specify the user as a foreign key.
And then also specify ordered in the exact
same way that we do have it here. And then
we'll just make migrations. And it's saying
that we're going to need to add some default
user. So what I'm going to do is, I'm just
going to set blank and no equal true on the
user. And I'm just going to quit, make migrations
again. And then we'll migrate. And then let's
run the server. Then here in the admin, I'm
going to just come here and specify the user
for both of these. Then I'll come back and
remove blank and No. And then make migrations
again. And now it says there are three options
so we can ignore for now. And then we'll migrate
and then run the server again. And then back
here in the view, we are getting or creating
the item. But there's a couple other conditions
we're going to add in here. So we'll say where
the item equals that item, the user equals
request on user and ordered equals false.
So that makes sure this last one ordered equals
false, that we're not getting an item that's
already been purchased. So if we come back
here, we can actually delete both of these.
And then I'll come and add to cart. And that's
because we need to add creates a day because
this is returning a tupple to us. Try that
again. Now we see that one there. And let's
open up the orders. And we see it's added
in there as well. If I add it again, let's
refresh this here. Now you see the quantity
is two and we don't have another one created
there which is good and it's added in there
as well. Cool. So that's all working. So we
can now focus on removing from the cart. So
if we come back here, it's also similarly
going to look like this. So we'll say define,
remove from cart, which takes a request and
a slug. And at the end of all of it, we're
going to return a redirect back to that slug.
And we're also going to need to get that item.
And we're going to need to get the order.
So I'm going to copy that query set there.
So we check if there is an order for this
user. That is not ordered yet. If the query
city exists, then we get that order. And I'll
say, else, we could then just return a redirect
back to that same place there. And I'll say,
add a message. So saying, the user doesn't
have an order. And then if the order does
exist, then we will check if the order contains
that item slug. Or we can get rid of those
two there. So we're getting the item, checking
if the user has an order. If they do have
an order, then we make sure we grab it. And
we then filter the order for that specific
item slug. If that order does contain the
order item, then we need to remove it. So
we can basically change this to remove. But
we also need to get that order item. And we
can just say, get rid of that else there.
So the order item will just grab here, using
this call there. And just say dot filter,
where item equals item use equals request
on user ordered equals false. And we can just
say, of zero. And then here, we'll just say
else, return another redirect. And here we'll
need to add a message saying that the order
does not contain this order item. So like
that. So let's see if this logic is correct.
We'll take that, bring it into the URLs. And
I'll just copy that and say this is remove
from CT. And then we can go into the template.
And I'm just going to go into the product.
And we're going to copy this here just for
testing, we're not going to actually keep
this here. So I'll just say remove from cart.
And we can go to the model as well. And then
paste this here and say get remove from cart
URL. And then this is also removed from cart,
then we can take that here. And I'll get rid
of entire line. And then the class er says
danger. And so let's see this now. So right
now, we have to have this item. So if I say
removed from cart, let's see here, this still
exists, which is fine. But if we come here,
now it's not there anymore. So it was successfully
removed. If I try remove from cart again,
then we're not seeing any of the errors come
through. And that's fine. So we'll probably
want to add messages as a last touch for this
video. So I'll just close these two off. And
we'll go to the top and also from Django dot
contrib import messages. And then we can come
down. And I'll add here we'll say messages,
dot info of the request and say this item
was added to your cart. And then we'll copy
that and put another one here and say this
item was updated. And I can say item quantity
was updated. And then I'll copy this and paste
that one there. So there we go, we can actually
make use this one. So this item was added
to your cart, and then further removed from
cart. If the order curious that exists. Then
here when we remove the item, we'll say this
item was removed from your cart. And then
Otherwise, we'll say this item was not in
your cart. And then you can get rid of that
comment there. And then here, we say the user
doesn't have an order. So we'll say, you do
not have an active order, and then get rid
of that comment there. And because we have
these return statements, inside these l statements,
I'm actually just going to add the return
there. And get rid of it there. Because we
are checking all of the boxes in these conditions.
Now we just need to add the messages into
the templates here. So let's just close out
there. And I'm going to come back here and
just look for the Django messages. Come here
to the framework. And if we just scroll down,
and we can copy this here. And we're going
to the templates into base that HTML. And
right here below the nav bar, just paste that
there. And actually, if you go to MD bootstrap,
calm to the jQuery Doc's components, alerts,
you can actually just make use of these alerts,
which we'll use for the messages. So I'm just
going to copy that over there. And instead
of creating an unordered list, I'll get rid
of the unordered list. And paste this over
here. And then the message I'll cut out and
paste there. And then the messages tags, I
will take and replace primary with that there.
And I'll just get rid of that. Now, let me
actually try and move this into the body instead.
And what I'm actually going to do is take
the return redirect and make sure that this
is also inside all of these conditions. And
just rearrange that. And then this last one
over there. So if I click Add to cart, now,
we can just inspect this, and double check
that we aren't getting an alert, which we
are, there it is. And what I'll do here is
just coming out margin, top 20 pixels. And
it's it's got to be quite a lot for us to
see it. So what I'm going to do is just create
a div here. And I'll specify the class as
margin top five. So then if we try this again,
and we can see it there, if I try and take
that PT for class. And you can see it's probably
as good as whole get, but let's just come
down. And you can see there are dismissible
ones. So let's take that. And now just paste
that inside there. And then take the messages
tags, replace warning with that day. And the
strong, I'm going to remove and put a message
in there. And we can get rid of that one.
So now if we come back here, if I say remove
from cart, and oh, we need to add PT for there.
So if I click Add to cart, there is that if
I click Remove from cart, if I try remove
from cart again, it says the item was not
in your cart. And if I go and refresh this
order here and delete this order, and then
come back and remove from cart, you do not
have an active order. If I try add to cart,
then it was added to the cart again. And you
can see there it is. So this is what we have.
So far, we have a list of products. And we
can view a detailed view of that product and
we can add it to the cart or remove it from
the cart. And in this video, we're going to
focus a lot on just improving the display
of the site. That being authentication as
one part, if we go to accounts login, you
can see here is our login page. And we're
going to try and style this to look a little
bit better. We also have some links that aren't
working such as this products link. And we're
going to try and touch up this page as well.
And also add a count of how many items are
in our cart. Let's go and jump into the HTML
to start fixing some of the style. And the
first page is the home that HTML that will
fix up. I basically want to just remove this
whole banner here. It's not really necessary
on this, you'd like to use it for something.
So this is, there's the third slide. And it's
everything inside these carousel items that
we're going to remove. There's the second
one. And there's the first one. So there it
is this entire slide stuff, basically just
going to remove that. And these indicators
as well. And then we will get rid of this
whole div here that has the controls as well.
So now let's take a look. And there we go.
Then I'm also going to remove the download
link there at the bottom. And I believe this
isn't actually in this file, this is in the
footer. So here we have the social icons.
And right above, there is the call to action,
we're going to remove that, refresh this.
And there we go. Then I'm also going to remove
the product link there. So that we can do
inside the navbar. And we'll just get rid
of it there. There we go. And then the home
link, and checkout link. And we're actually
also going to remove, and we'll just say that
this DJ ecommerce, this logo is what you'll
press to go to the home view here, I'm just
going to comment this out, because maybe you
want to use it to specify something there.
And okay, that style is a little bit messed
up. So let's just comment out the list items
instead. There we go. And so then here on
the right hand side, we don't want to show
the cost if the user is not authenticated
yet. So we'll come inside here. And I'm going
to copy that list item. And he will say, if
requested user is authenticated. Then we will
show that item. And I'll say else, then we'll
show this item. And we'll get rid of that
eye tag there. Get rid of the span there.
And this is just going to be login. And then
the H ref here. I'll specify it as a URL.
So this will be Account Login. And if we refresh
that, now it says login. If we click that,
it takes us to this page. And what I'll also
do is add another list item here and say this
is logged out. And we'll do another one for
sign up. And this will be account, sign up.
And this is account lockout. So if we refresh
this, never you have it. And so to style this
page, we're going to need the templates. And
that comes from Django all auth scarab repository,
so we're just going to search for it. And
I'm just going to download it. And what you're
going to want to do is just go in the auth
directory, and copy the templates directory.
So Copy that. And then when you come back
in here, you're going to want to paste it
and make sure you don't overwrite our templates
folder already. So I'm going to add it in
here. Okay, there it is. I've added the templates
directory, and I'm going to move those three
folders there. And then we have the base that
HTML file that it uses. So I'm going to copy
all of those contents. And we'll paste them
here in ours. Then I'll remove this div that
has all the links, because we don't need that.
And I've removed block content because we
already using block content. And I'll take
the extra body and put that underneath there.
And also get rid of the messages because we
already have messages here. And then I'll
take all of that stuff that's inside the head.
And I'll come pasted there so we can get rid
of ours. And then other than that, there's
nothing else so we can get rid of all of that.
And now we have access to these templates.
So I'm going to delete that templates directory.
And we can go into the account login dot html
file. And if we compare this to the home dot
html file, we basically want to see what containers
we need to put our content inside to make
it look consistent. So there would look to
be the main and the container for clothes,
the navbar there, there's a section and then
a div with row while fade in. So I'm actually
just going to copy that and then we'll just
try and paste all of that here inside the
block content. And of course, we don't want
the navbar so I'm going to get rid of the
entire navbar. And then we'll just close off
all of these tags and I'm going to take all
of this And just cut that out and paste that
here in that row. And we can try and tab this
in. Cool. So that's what it looks like. So
if we go back, and let's just refresh this
page. And okay, let's come back in here. And
we'll add a div with a class of column 12.
And then down here, Okay, there we go. And
I'm going to remove the text center. And I
think we'd probably like to make use of Django
crispy forms. But until we install that, let's
just change the class for this, submit or
sign in button to button primary. And then
this all says button, default for the Forgot
Password. So if we refresh that, and so let's
go and install Django crispy forms, we can
just say pip install Django, crispy forms.
There we go. I'm also going to say PIP freeze
into requirements dot txt. And now we need
to go into our settings. So DJ e commerce
settings, base, and we're going to just go
to the bottom here, also for crispy forms.
And this is just going to be the crispy template
pack, which is bootstrap four. And then in
login dot html, I'll go here to the top. And
I'll just say load crispy forms tags. And
here at the form, I'll change this to crispy.
And then we can refresh this. And okay, not
a registered library. That's right, we need
to add it in our installed apps as well. So
here, just add crispy forms. And we can come
back and refresh this. And that looks a lot
better. And so perhaps, we'd also like to
just bring that in a little bit. So if we
just come up here, this could be column six,
and offset three. And there we go. I'm not
going to go and do the signup page as well.
But as a practice, you could probably try
and do that yourself. You can see it's pretty
straightforward. So if I go and login, then
it redirects us to accounts slash profile.
And what I'm going to do is just go here to
the base.pi. And down here, I'll say that
the login, redirect URL equals slash, so that
we can at least redirect to a URL that we
have on the site. And there it says you've
signed in. And we also have the option to
log out, I'm going to go and log out and just
sign out there. And let's try and log in again
to see if the redirect works. And it does
cool. So now we can work on this pagination.
And this is actually very simple. If we just
go back here, I can close this. And all we
need to do is just go to our view. So that's
in core views. And it's the home view. So
inheriting from a ListView. And we can specify
the paginate by which is a field on the class.
And we could say paginate by, let's say one
just to see that it works. And if we come
back and refresh this, now we see that there's
only one. And we can just change these numbers
here to match the query set. So let's go back
into home dot html. And we'll scroll down
here to the pagination. And so right here
above the nav, I'm going to add a condition
and say if is paginated. And this is something
being passed in by the class based view, so
in the context, and then right here underneath
it, then also and if so if we come back, now
you can see that it is paginated, which means
that this is a variable in the context. And
then here above the previous error, I'm going
to say if the page object dot has previous,
then we will show this link and then just
say and if. So if we go back, refresh this.
Now that arrow is gone, because this is the
first page of the query set. So you can't,
you can't go backwards you can only go forwards.
So right here we'll do the same kind of logic.
Just say if page object dot has next and then
say endif. And we do So now we need to add
the link inside this H ref. And this is going
to be question mark page equals two. So we're
setting the page variable. If I set this equal
to two, and we just see what this does, then
if I click it, it takes us to page two, and
there's the second item. So instead of it
being a static variable, you want this to
be dynamic. And this is going to come from
the page object. So we'll say page object
dot next page number. Then if we refresh this,
and let's just go back to page one, and you
click it, then it goes to page two. And then
we'll do the same thing for the back arrow.
So if we come down, so in there, this will
be page equals page object dot previous page.
Number nine, we can refresh this. And we can
click it, that's because this is disabled.
So let's refresh this. And if you click that,
now you can go back between those pages. And
just to be simple, I'm not going to output
all of these numbers, I'm only going to show
the current page that we're on. So what I'll
do is get rid of all of those items. And we're
only showing the active item. And this is
going to be equal to page equals page object
DOT number. And then we'll I'll put that exact
same thing over there. So now let's refresh
this. And it says to nonce is one. Cool. So
that's at least working. I'm gonna go back
here to the view, though. So let's just close
templates. And back here, I'm going to paginate
this by, let's say 10. And then we can refresh
this. And now we don't have page two. So there
we go. And so now let's display the current
item count here in the navbar. And we're going
to do this with a template tag. So here inside
core, we'll just create a template tags directory.
And inside, they will create the cart template
tags, which will be a Python file. And here,
we just need to say from Django import template.
And then we need to import our model. So we'll
say from core dot models, import order. And
then we'll say that register equals to template
dot library, this so that we can register
our template tag. And we just have to define
a function, which is going to be the name
of the template tag. And we can say this is
the cart item count, which we're going to
say takes in a user. And above this function,
we just say add to register dot filter. And
first we need to check if the user is authenticated.
Because if they aren't, then we don't want
to show that they have something in a cart.
So we're going to say that the query set equals
to order dot objects dot filter. And we can
check the model here on the order. So we can
filter it by the user and say we're user equals
to user. But also, making sure that ordered
is false. So we don't want to get their previously
ordered orders. And then we'll just say, if
the query is said exists, we'll return query
set of zero. So getting the only order in
that query set, and then we're going to get
a count of the number of items in the order.
So we'll say dot items, dot count. Otherwise,
if the user is not authenticated, then we'll
just return zero. So now that we have the
cart item count as a template tag, we just
need to go into the navbar, because that's
where the cart count is displayed. So right
here at the top, we're going to need to load
in our template tag. So we'll just call load.
And this is going to be the name of the file.
So that'll be caught template tags. And then
we can take our function name. And we can
come down here to that number one. And here
we just pass the request on user, which is
already in the template. And then using the
pipe operator, we can call our cart item count
on there to display the count. So let's see
what this looks like. If I refresh this says
it's not registered, and this could be just
from not refreshing the server there Go. Now
we see there's one item in the cart. And we
can try and remove from the cart and see which
one it was. And there we go, now it's back
down to zero. If I add it to cart again, now
it's at one. And that sums up what we wanted
to do in this video. If you've enjoyed it,
leave a comment down below and let us know
what you think so far. In the next few videos,
we're going to get started with the order
summary displaying all the items in the cart,
and also taking a look at that fancied checkout
form that we saw earlier on. So in this one,
we're going to focus on our cart right now
if we click on this button, it doesn't take
us anywhere. And that's what we're going to
deal with. Now, we're going to create a view
that can display all of the items that are
in the cart, and also add functionality to
either remove the item from the cart, or increase
the quantity of that item. So first, we're
going to need a view. So let's come here inside
core views, and racha. Beneath the home view,
I'm going to create the order summary view.
And this is going to be a detail view that
inherits from now we just need to specify
the model as the order. And then we'll say
that the template name equals to let's say,
order summary dot html, then we can take this,
bring it into URLs. And we'll just create
a path there which can go to order summary.
And I'll use the exact same path as the name.
And then we'll make sure we use this order
summary.as view. Cool, then we can go into
the templates. And we'll create that file.
So that's order summary dot html, let's just
make sure that we don't put this inside the
accounts folder. There we go. Now I'm just
going to copy everything from let's go with
home dot html. just paste it all there. And
we're going to need to make use of a table
here. So if you go to the MD bootstrap.com
docs in jQuery tables, here, they are some
examples of how to use tables using their
styling. And I'm just going to use the responsive
table, we just come down all the way there,
then we can grab hold of this code, I'm just
going to copy it. And we don't need any of
these links or buttons. So everything there
in the nav bar we can get rid of. And the
section for products almost to get rid of
that. The pagination, I'll get rid of as well.
So we're just pasting it inside this container.
And let's just save that. And we'll go to
slash order summary. And okay, mistake, either
primary key or slugging. That's right. So
actually, we're going to do is make this inherit
from view instead of detail view. And we can
just define this on our own. So what are some
of you then we don't need any of that. But
we need to define the get method. Let's take
since self ogs, and keyword arcs, I'm just
going to say return a render of the request.
And this is going to go there. And you can
pass in self dot request. There we go. And
Alright, so there's our table showing, we
can come back here and just above the table,
we can actually just tab it in Karachi, I'll
just add an h2 and say, order summary. So
here in the table, we're just going to display
information about the items that are added
into this order. And that means we're going
to need to take a look here at the order item.
So we have the actual item. And that means
we can display pretty much all of this information.
So the title, the price discount price. If
we want to we could display the rest of these,
although it might not be that necessary, add
an order summary. Then we still have the order
item so we can specify the quantity of that
item. So that's basically what we're going
to display. So here in the table, we're going
To create those columns, and the first one
is going to be the item title. So that's the
title here on this model, then we can display
the price. And then we can display the quantity.
And then we can do the total item price. So
meaning if you have a price of $10, and the
quantity is two, then here, we want to see
the total item price, that would be 20. So
we'll do it like that. And that means we only
need four columns there. And we actually,
we don't need all of these rows, we can get
rid of that. And here, we're going to loop
through the order. So we'll say for item in
object, dot items, and then just say n for.
And this should rather be items dot all because
it's a many to many field. And actually, we
could add another column in here and just
put that hash back as like the increment.
And then here, we'll put the count inside
the for loop. But for now, let's just get
those fields displaying. So that's going to
be item dot title. And we just need to make
sure we're going to be getting order items.
So that means we should rather call this order
item. And then this will be Order Item dot
item dot title, then we have the price. So
that's going to be Order Item dot item, dot
price. And then we'll have the quantity. So
this is just going to be Order Item dot quantity.
Because that's on the order item model. And
then we have the total item price, which let's
just put some question marks there. So if
we come back here, we aren't passing anything
into the context yet. So that means here in
the view, we're going to need to get the order.
So we'll say that order order dot objects,
dot get, and we'll say user equals self dot
request dot user, all say ordered equals false.
And then here at the top, we can import from
Django as exceptions. So we'll say from Django
dot call dot exceptions, import object does
not exist. And then we can just say, try do
this. And then say, except object does not
exist, then we'll have to raise an error.
So we could either raise it, or we could just
say return a redirect, and just say, to slash
for now. And we can just say, messages dot
error. And we'll say, parsing this request
and say, you do not have an active order.
And just pass in self dot request. And we
might as well place that there. So now if
we come back and refresh this, now we have
anonymous user object is not iterable. So
we need to ensure that our user is authenticated
for some of these views. One of them clearly
is the order summary view. And some of these
other views would be like the add to cart
and the removed from cart. So let's go import
from Django dot contrib dot auth dot decorators,
and we'll import login required. So here on
these function based views, we can at least
say app login required above both of these.
So we ensure that you have to be logged in
to call these methods. Then for the order
summary, we're going to need to do the same
kind of logic. And we're going to use a mixin
for this. And this is just almost from the
same path. It's from Django dot contrib dot
auth dot mixins. And we're importing the login
required mixin. And then we just come here
and pass it in as the first argument that
our class inherits from. So that now if we
come back and refresh, this now redirects
us to the sign in page and let's just sign
in. So now we've signed in, and we aren't
getting anything showing there. And that's
because we still need to pass this audit into
the context. So let's do that. Now. We'll
say this is the object and that is the order
and then just pass the sin. So there we have
that item. There's the price, there's the
quantity. And now we need to think about how
we can display a total item price. And we
could simply do this on the order item. So
here on the model, we could define a method
that takes the self quantity and multiplies
it by the item price. So we'll say, define
get total item price takes itself. And we
can just say return self dot quantity, multiplied
by self dot item, dot price. Now, we also
have the discount price. So that means that
we're going to need a method that does the
same sort of logic, but for the discount price.
So we'll just say get total discount item
price. And instead of multiplying by the price,
we're going to multiply by the discount price.
So then here on the order summary, we now
need to know if the order is on sale, or on
discount, then we're going to display that
discount total price. Otherwise, we display
the normal total price. So we'll just say
if Order Item, dot item, discount price. So
if there is a discount price, then we'll say
else and say and if so again, if there is
a discount price, then we're going to output
the get total discount price. So like this.
And then Otherwise, we'll just get the normal
total price. And we could put dollars in front
of that. So refresh this now. And we get 300.
And that's because this item is on discount.
And what we could do to make this even fancier
is by creating a method that gets the amount
that the person is saving on this item. So
we can say, Get amount saved for self, and
just say return this method. So self dot get
total price minus the discount price. And
that's how much you're saving. So then we
can come back here. And if there is a discount
price, then we'll say saving. And then say
Order Item dot get amount saved. Come back
here. And there we see saving $300. And we
could make this a little bit nicer with a
label. And we can come back here to see those
components. So if we go components, tags,
labels, and badges, and then just scroll down
here for this span tag. And then we can put
this all inside a span tag actually. And then
just come here to the end. And let's see what
this looks like saving 300. And we can get
rid of the brackets there. I'm just going
to leave it like this small just to show you
the principle and how you can create extra
functionality like this pretty quickly. And
let's just go and add another item. So this
one is not on sale, I'll add that to cart.
We'll go back to the codons, let's actually
get that URL there. So then the nav bar here
to the cart, we need to add an href here.
And this is just going to go to a URL. And
let's just check what that URL name is. And
that's all the summary. And if we come back,
refresh this. And we forgot the namespace,
let's just check what the namespace is so
cool. There we go. Now, if I click caught
now takes a stay. Cool. So both of these items
are displaying the correct total item price.
And now we want to display the order total.
So that would just be summing both of these
values together. And we can also go and fix
this order number there. So let's just go
back here. And we can change this to be for
loop counter. And then just refresh this.
There we go. Now that's looking good. And
so in a similar way That we did here by checking
if there is a discount price and then displaying
it otherwise displaying this, we're going
to create a similar method that does that
same logic here on the order item, which is
basically to get the final price. And that's
just so we don't have to keep repeating this,
if there's a discount price logic. So we'll
say define, get final price. And we're just
going to say if self dot item, dot discount
price, return self dot get total discount,
and then say otherwise return self dot get
total item price. And this is so that on the
order, we can calculate a total. So we can
just say, Get total. And here, we're going
to do this in a lazy way by saying the total
equals zero. And saying for order item in
self dot items, dot all, then we'll say total
plus equals to order item, dot, get final
price. And then just say return total. And
then here on the order summary, right off
to the table, in its own row, I'll create
one column. And this is going to be object,
because that's the order. And we're going
to say dot get total, and then just put dollars
in front of that. And okay, this is inside
the for loop, let's make sure that that's
outside the for loop. And there we go, we
can just make sure that this is spanning across
the entire table. So I'll say column span
equals to five. And then we'll just come here,
above it, and I'm going to create another
column. And this one, I'm actually going to
give the column span of four. And this is
just going to say, order total. And I'll say
this is in bold. And we can refresh that.
And also make the total itself bold. And then
we can also go and add another row. And this
row is going to be just a column span of five.
And we'll say that there's a button in here,
or rather an anchor tag. And I'll just say
Proceed to Checkout. And for now, we can just
say that this href takes us to slash checkout.
And then check this Yeah, then we can give
this a class and say button button, let's
say warning. And I'm also going to say, float.
Right. Cool. And I'm just going to change
this to four as well. Okay, there it is, if
I click on that, it takes us to this checkout
page, and also add another button in there.
So let's just display them here. So this first
one we can just say is primary. And it's going
to go back to just slash for now. And we'll
say, continue shopping. And I'm going to change
the order of those two. And I'll just say,
margin left. So continue shopping takes you
back here. And then lastly, here inside the
for loop, we're going to need to handle if
the cart is empty. So if it's empty, then
we'll just display a row. And then this is
also just going to be one column. And we can
say column span equals five. And we'll just
say your cart is empty. And our copy this
row there, we can get rid of this Proceed
to Checkout. So all you can do is just continue
shopping. And then we also want to make sure
if there is an order, then we display this
order total. Otherwise we don't display anything.
So we'll say if object dot get total And then
say end if, and then we can check this out.
So let's say we go and remove those items.
And we can actually add some buttons here,
right next to the quantity. So we can change
that. So here, let's go to this order item
quantity, we're going to add some icons in
there. So if we come here, I can just search
for icons, and you get an icons list. And
I'm just going to search for plus. So there
we go. So I'll take that, and we can put that
on the right hand side. And then if we search
for minus, copy that one, and paste that on
the other side, then if we see what this looks
like, and I'm just going to say margin, right
to and margin left to, there we go. So we
want these tools to be buttons. So we're going
to wrap them in anchor tags. And we'll just
output this a little bit better. Call it save
this, refresh that. So now there are buttons,
at least. And this is going to be the Remove
from cart. And the plus is going to be the
add to cart. Because if we take a look here
at the views, we have functionality to check
if that order item is already in there, then
we're just incrementing the quantity. And
then here in the Remove from cart, we actually
don't have that functionality. So what I'm
going to do is just copy that, paste it here,
and this is going to remove, maybe let's call
this single item from cart. So we're getting
the item checking if the order exists. If
it does, we grab the order, we check if the
order item is in the order. And instead of
removing it, we're just going to decrease
the quantity. So if we see how that was done
on this add to cart, we're grabbing the order
item quantity and saying plus equals one.
So here, we just say minus equals one, and
then save it, don't remove it from the cart,
and then just say this item quantity was updated.
And then I'm not going to redirect back to
the core product. Instead, this is going to
be order summary. And I'm just going to leave
it like this on that one. So now let's take
this and bring it into the URLs. And then
we'll just copy and paste that there. And
say this is remove single item from cart.
And we'll say remove item from cart like that.
So now we can use this in the href. So if
we minus the href is going to be a URL, which
will go to that URL, and then we need to pass
in the slug. So that's going to be Order Item
dot item dot slug. So let's go and test this
out. And this is call as the namespace. And
okay, let's go back to the copy. So now if
I click minus and it's returning a redirect,
oh, we've forgotten, we don't need to pass
in slug into that URL. So now let's just go
back, refresh this. Okay. Now we're on four.
If I click that, now we're on three. Cool.
So that is working. If I say plus, we haven't
linked that one yet. But it's going to be
pretty similar. So let's just paste that there
and make sure that we use the Add to Cart
name. And let's refresh this. If I click Add.
And okay, we're redirecting. And it actually
might be a good idea that it just redirects
back to the order summary in that view, as
well. So here in Add To Cart when we increment
the quantity, we're just going to go redirect
them there. And also in that case, and in
that case. Cool. So let's refresh this go
back to the cart. Click the plus. Right, we
don't need the slug passed in there anymore.
Okay, refresh that. And let's test it again.
Now. So we see it seems to be working and
The pricing is also changing along with that
course. So that's pretty good. Lastly, I think
we could add a trashcan here on the right
hand side, which could be if maybe you have
20 of the same item here, and you don't want
to click the minus button to get back to zero.
So you'd rather just click the trashcan. So
that means here in the order summary, in this
last column here, right here is where we're
going to add another one of those icons. So
let's just search for trash. And I'll copy
that one. Paste that there. And just make
sure we wrap this in an anchor tag as well.
And instead of it being removed single item,
this is going to be the removed from cart.
So that is just removed from cart. So paste
that there. Cool. Let's refresh this. And
let's also go and add here float, right. Just
refresh that. There we go. And I think we
could also add some style and just say color
is red. Refresh that. Cool. Now, if I click
to delete that, okay, let's also go back here
to the view removed from cards, we're going
to say goes to order summary, and get rid
of the slug. And otherwise, these two will
just let it redirect back to the product.
That's fine. So let's go back here to the
cart. And if I click to remove it, your cart
is empty, continue shopping, add to cart,
redirects us back here, increased quantity,
decrease, if I subtract again, then we're
on zero. Now think how we should handle this
is if it goes down to zero, then it's removed
from the order. So let's go here to the view.
And this is the Remove single item. So here,
we'll say if Order Item, dot quantity is greater
than one, then we will subtract one from the
quantity. Otherwise, we should just say, removed
from the order. So order items, remove that
order item. And I'll bring the order items
save there as well. So that seems right. Let's
go back here. And let's increase the quantity.
Okay, now if I subtract, now it's gone. Cool.
So all of this seems to be working pretty
well. And in the next video, we can get started
with that checkout view, and look at how we
can handle the billing address and shipping
address of the user. Alright, so this is what
we have so far, we have these items, we can
view them, we can add them to a cart, we can
go to the cart and see them here. And we can
proceed to checkout, where we're now dealing
with this checkout form. And so this is what
we're going to be handling in this video.
And basically just handle the process of getting
the user's billing address and physical address
to ship to and at the end of this, then being
able to redirect them to the payment method
that they select. Now, there's also some stuff
on here that we're not going to use, such
as the first name, last name, username, and
the email, because we already have that, but
we will keep most of this. And so let's go
into that checkout form HTML file. So that's
templates, and then check out that HTML. And
here is everything. And I'm going to get started
by removing everything we don't need. So that's
this last name and first name, I can get rid
of the entire row there. We don't need the
user name. We don't need the email. So if
we save this, and refresh this, and there's
quite a big gap here. So let's just remove
this class there and see what this does. Yeah,
that's much better. And one thing to note
is that we're not going to display this name
on the card credit card information here,
because there are options to select your payment
method. And we're going to handle that in
a separate view, not in this same view. So
we can go down there and get rid of all of
that. So that's this entire row here with
the name on the card and credit card and the
expiration date as well. So this entire row
and if we save this Cool, and who also come
here to the credit and debit card, I'm going
to get rid of one of them here. And let's
just say this is stripe for now. So now we
need to think about the type of form that
we're going to create, are we going to use
a Django form or are we just going to use
plain HTML and accept the data in the post
request? Now, I'm more proud of the method
of creating the Django form. So we're going
to do that we're going to go into coal and
create forms.py and say, from Django import
forms. And we'll say this is the checkout
form. And so it comes from forms dot form.
And if we look here, at the form, we have
the address, which is kind of like the street,
and then we have the other apartment, or sweet,
the country, the state and the zip code, now
there's a package that we can use to handle
selecting countries, and that we'll get into
in a bit, but the state, we're not going to
use, so I'm going to remove that option and
only use the zip code. If there are packages
that handle the states, then you can obviously
go and add another field to take that input
in. But we're just going to remove it for
simplicity. So we can get rid of that column
there. So back here in the form, we're going
to start adding those fields. The first one
was the street. And we'll just say street
address, we'll say this as a character field,
then we had the, let's just call it the apartment
address. And so this is also a character field,
and I'm going to say required, equals false.
And that's just because here it says it's
optional. So we'll go along with that. Then
we have the country, and we can make use of
Django countries, which is a package we're
going to install. So here, you can go to the
GitHub repository. And you can see all about
it. So if we click on installation, all you
have to do is just run pip install Django
countries. And I'm going to run PIP freeze
into the requirements. And there we go. Then
I'll run the server. So we need to go and
add Django countries to our installed apps
as well. So here in settings base, I'll come
up here and just add this in. And then we
have an example, country field. So all we
do is just import the country field from Jango
countries, and then specify that field on
the model. So that's what we're going to do.
We'll come here into forms. And there's a
country field. And I'm going to specified
in the exact same way. And here, they actually
have blank label as a parameter, which can
just be select country by default. So we can
do that. Cool. So that's the country, we'll
see that in action in a bit. Then we have
these zip code. So I'm going to say zip equals
forms dot character field as well. And then
we have this option, shipping address is the
same as my billing address. And we'll think
about how to handle this. But for the time
being, let's just keep going. Then we have
the save this information for next time. So
these are both checkboxes, and I'm going to
add them in but we're not going to deal with
functionality for them just yet. So we have
same billing address. And we'll say this is
equal to forms dot Boolean field. And I'm
going to say that the widget equals to a checkbox
input, then we have save info, which is also
going to be a checkbox input. And then we
have the payment options. So there will have
payment option, which will be also a Boolean
field, I'm going to say widget equals forms
dot radio select. So that way, we can only
select one at a time. And so let's start taking
this into a view. So we'll come here. And
this is going to be inside the checkout view
here. And I'm going to change this into a
class based view as well. So we'll call this
the checkout view. And I'm going to make this
inherit from the default view. Then we can
say define the get request. And then we're
just going to render that self dot request.
And then we're going to need to get our form
and pass that into the context. Then we have
the POST method, which also just takes in
ogs keyword dogs. And they will deal with
the post request of that form. So let's go
and say import from dot forms, the checkout
form. And then here, we'll say form equals
checkout form. And I'll say context. form,
is that form. And then I'll just pass the
context in here. Then the same kind of logic
here, form equals that and we'll say request
dot post, or none. And this should be self
dot request, then we'll say if form.is valid,
I'm just going to say print form as valid,
then we can just say return a redirect to,
let's see what URLs we have. Yeah. So we can
go back to checkout. So that'll just be core
Checkout, like that. And now let's take that
checkout view, and replace it there. And then
say.as view. Alright, so now let's come back
and refresh this. And now we're going to need
to go into here. And I'm going to come just
to the top here, and create another form,
passing the CSRF token. And then I'll put
the form. And we also have Django as crispy
forms installed. So we can come to the top
here, and say load crispy forms, tags. And
then here on the form, we'll say crispy. And
I'm just going to add a button as well. And
I'll just say class is button button primary.
And say type is submit. Now let's refresh
this. And there's a spelling mistake this
CSRF. Okay, and then let's just come here
and say, check out. Alright, so there's our
form. And we'll worry about the styling in
a second, we'll get it to look like this.
But we have the street address, apartment
address, the zip code, same billing address,
save info, and then we aren't getting the
payment options coming through. And that's
very simple to fix, we can just come here
and specify our payment choices. And this
is going to be a tupple of topples. I'll say
the first one is just s, which is for stripe.
And then the second one will say is p which
is PayPal. And then we just specify these
choices here in the radio select. And this
is not meant to be a knee. This is meant to
be as a second argument. And it's changed
this to a choice field. Alright, let's try
that again. There we go. Now they're coming
through. And you can only select one at a
time, which is correct. And now we can worry
about styling this to look the same. So what
we need to do is take a look at the HTML.
So let's go back here. And inside this form,
we need to look at all of the fields. So you
can see that, for example, this first one,
the ID of address, has a class of form control,
but it's inside these divs. So what we could
do is instead of outputting the form, just
like this, we could loop through all the fields
in the form or just access the fields directly.
So for example, I'm just going to comment
that out. And here I'll say, form dot dot
street address, because that's this field.
So if I come back and refresh this, now it's
still there, it loses the placeholder. But
we can come and specify the attributes inside
here. So I'll say widget equals forms dot
text input. And I'll say attributes where
the placeholder is let's get that exact same
placeholder here. And then we can come back
and refresh those. And there we go. There's
our placeholder. So we can go and do the exact
same thing for the rest of these. So I'll
just comment this one out. And you'll say
form dot, and this is the apartment address.
And then here we'll grab this exact same widget
posted in there. And the placeholder will
say is, apartment or suite. Let's take a look.
Okay, there we go, apartment or suite. Then
we have the country. And we can go and see
how they output the country. And actually,
let's go back here to the form and we'll say,
dot form field. And let's come back and refresh
this. There we go. Now we have that country
field showing up and you have all these countries,
which is pretty cool. So we can come here,
back inside the HTML. And here, when we choose,
we basically can just comment out the entire
select field, and then just output form dot
NSS. country. And we can see here it has a
class and an ID, so we can go back. And in
here, I'm just going to specify attributes.
And let's see here, if class. And we'll get
that class here. That's custom select. So
like this. And then if we come back here,
and cool. So that styling works in the zip
code is simply just the zip code. So we can
just come here and say form dot zip, and refresh
this. And cool, same thing. And then we can
come back. And now we have this shipping address.
So I'll just comment that one out. And we'll
say form dot. And this is same billing as
shipping, then we have the Save info. So this
will be form dot save info. And then we have
the two inputs. So I'm just going to comment
that out. And we'll put form dot payment option.
And this could not work because it's inside
one dove. Let's refresh this. And yeah, so
instead, we can just come above here and say
for value, comment text in form dot payment
option, dot choices. And then after that in
for. So we're basically creating a div for
every input. And then we can actually comment
out our own output there and bring back the
input that was here, already. And then the
text will say is this name, you can actually
change it to name. And then the value will
come here, inside the label, and I'll put
it there. Then the ID I'm going to change
to name and specify the for value as name
as well. So let's go back and see here. And
oh, we've got an end comment to get rid of
that. And if we come down, and Okay, it's
not up putting. And this is because it should
be formed on fields, not payment options.
And if we just inspect this, then we can open
up the label we have as as the label, but
for the input, the ID is stripe and the name
is stripe. So that means that value is this
first value in the tupple. And then name is
the second value. So we actually don't need
to use value that much. So I'm going to change
it to name just so we can display it. So if
we refresh this, now we have stripe and PayPal,
the enriching comment out that second div.
So let's come back. Cool, and we just need
to make sure that they're both not checked.
And now you can notice that we can actually
select them both. And that's because the name,
if we see here, the name was payment method.
And if you want to only be able to select
one of the radio options, you need them both
to have the same name. So payment method is
the right way to go. So we can refresh this.
And now, we only able to select one at a time,
which is correct. But our shipping address
isn't working. And that's because the full
value is being applied to something that doesn't
have that ID. And actually, to make this a
lot easier, what we can do is, we can bring
back our inputs, we can just refresh the page,
we can inspect these two, and then we get
name equals save info for the one. So we can
come here and specify that there. And then
the other one is name equals same billing
address. So we just put that there. And then
what we can do is, we can say, if form that
same billing address, then we'll say, checked,
and then say, and if and then we can take
that, bring it here in the input, form that
save info then checked. And you can get rid
of that and actually remove some of the spacing
there. Okay, or refresh this, come down. And
there we go. And then we can also go here
to the form. And we can say required equals
false for both of these because they're not
required, then we can come back and refresh
this. And we can see they're both checked
by default, let's just add on the end of these
dot value. refresh this, there we go. Now,
by default, they're unselected. And now everything
seems to be working. So we can go and remove
the form that we created up top. So that form
there. And okay, so the styling is all gone
there. Okay, so we can just go here to Django
countries. And we can make use of the country's
select widget. So we can just import this.
And then here, when we call dot form field,
we can pass in the widget as this country,
select widget. So now say widget, like that.
And then inside there, we can specify those
attributes. So this will be class. And that
class is that there. And then if we go back
and refresh this, there we go, now we're getting
that styling coming through. And then we can
just dial that zip code, which just has form
control. So we can go back here, or say widget
equals forms dot text input, and specify the
attributes. And then just say, class, form,
control. Come back. And there we go. Alright,
so now all the styling looks fine. Now we
can handle what happens when we actually submit
the form. So back here in the view, we have
the post request, and we're just going to
print that form, cleaned data and see what
comes through. So we'll just refresh this,
enter some stuff in here, select a country.
I'll select both of those, and let's say stripe
continue. And okay, we need to make sure that
form is a POST request form. And we must add
a CSRF token. So let's try again and select
stripe. And we didn't return a response. So
here in the view, obviously, our form is not
coming through correctly. So what I'm going
to do is say print, self dot request, dot
post. And then here we'll say return. We'll
do the exact same return there and we'll just
say messages. dot info, or we could say warning,
and pass in self dot request and say failed
to Check out, then we can come back. And if
we enter some data, okay failed to check out.
So we've got the CSRF middleware token, we
have that street address, apartment address,
country is up, same billing address, save
info and payment method. And this could be
the payment option, because payment method
is specified as the name. So let's just come
back here. And I'm going to uncomment the
form. And let's just upload it again here
and make sure that we have the correct names
for each input. So we've got street address
for that. First one. And if we come down and
inspect that one, we have street address.
If we look at the payment option, here, for
the radio options, we have name equals payment
option. All right, so let's come down here,
all the way to these radio options. And then
the name needs to be payment option. And then
we're going to test what the request looks
like when we submitted in this form. So let's
just refresh this. And we'll just enter some
data there. And check out. Now let's go back.
And if we take a look here, so the query dictionary
is what we get here in the self dot request
dot post. And there we can see all the fields
coming through. And we get payment option
is S. Now let's go back and fill out this
form. Come back. And now you can see payment
option is on. So that's where the mistake
is, we need to make sure that the value that
this payment option contains is either s or
p not on. So that means back here, we can
also comment that out. And if we just go down
here to the payment option choices, we can
just add a value into the input. And this
is going to be that value variable that's
being looped through that we saw earlier was
either s or p. So now if we go back and refresh
this, and let's submit some data here. Now
it seems like it worked. And we see the form
is valid. Cool. So that is working. Now, we
can come and get rid of all these print statements.
And what we want to do is grab all of those
values that we saw here in the print statement.
And we're going to get them using the form
cleaned data. And then we're going to create
a billing address. So we'll just come here
to the models. And we're going to create this
model here. So we'll say class billing address
comes from models that model, we're going
to assign a user, and this is just going to
be a foreign key just like this user field
is. And then we're basically just going to
add all the values that this form has. So
that's street address. And that's a character
field will say maximum length is, let's say
100. Then we have the apartment address, country,
zip, and copy all of those, paste them there.
And these two are both character fields, but
the country is not. So if we go back here
to Django countries, we're going to need to
add it as a field. So you can see here countries
is a country field and it says multiple equals
true, which we're going to say it's false.
So we can just come here, like that, and make
sure that we import this correctly as well.
And that should be the same import, as we
saw here. So we'll just go to the top, imported
there, and the server still running. Cool.
So now we have this billing address model.
And I'm just going to say define string of
self. And I'll just say return self dot user
dot user name. And we are going to need to
make migrations. So we'll run that and then
run migrate. Then we can run the server Again.
And so now when we submit this form, we're
going to want to create the billing address
for this user. And then on the order, we're
going to need to create a field that references
the billing address, so that when we complete
the order, we can then attach the billing
address, to know where to send it, and also
the shipping address. And then we'll just
add billing address here and say, This is
a foreign key to the billing address. And
we'll say on Delete equals to, let's say,
models dot set, no. And I'll say, blank and
no equal true as well. And then we can go
back here, make migrations, migrate, and run
the server. And now here in the view, we'll
get all of that data. So that's all of these
fields here on the form. So I'm just going
to copy them all. And we'll just paste them
all here equals to form dot cleaned data,
dot get, and then that value. So now we have
all of those values, we're then going to import
our model, which is the billing address. So
let's come here and import that from top models.
And then we're going to say, the billing address,
equals billing address. And here, we're just
going to pass in all of these values for the
model. So that's user. So user equals to self
dot request dot user, then we have street
address, and all of these street address equals
street address, apartment address equals apartment
address. And we've got countries this isn't,
we were meant to set that to false. And we'll
say this is country. All right, make migrations
to fix that. I'm just gonna say one, and also
China, and then migrate, and then just run
server. Right, now we fix that. So then here,
we can say that the country equals to the
country. And we can say, zip equals zip, then
we can say billing address dot save. And then
we need to add the billing address to the
order here in the post request, we should
actually check if the audit exists already.
So let's just come down. And I'll basically
copy all of this, there, and then just paste
that here. So we're trying to get the order
based on the user. And we can basically get
rid of that context there. And if the object
doesn't exist, then we don't have an order.
So we just redirect them back. And I'll say,
go back to to the order summary, and everything
and paste that inside the try statement. just
paste that there. So if the order exists,
then we'll check if the form submission was
valid. And then we will take this order here
after we've saved the billing address. And
we'll say order dot billing address, equals
billing address, and then order dot save.
And so now if this is a successful post request,
then we also need to check which payment option
was selected, and redirect the user to that
view that will handle that specific payment
option. The same info that we've also gotten,
and the same billing address, these are two
slightly more advanced fields that we're not
going to do anything with just yet, so I'm
going to comment them out. And above here,
we'll just say to do add functionality for
these fields. And the implementation of the
Save info is a little bit confusing, because
in order for us to deliver something to that
address, we'll need to store the address.
So it's confusing as to how we could do this
without saving the information as we kind
of needed to deliver that object to them.
So if you have any proposals on how to handle
that, leave a comment down below. Otherwise,
we're just going to leave it commented out
for now. The same billing address which is
meant to be same shipping address. Let's just
come here, change this to same shipping address.
And then here, this is same shipping address.
Then here In the view, this would be same
shipping address, where we get the value of
same shipping address. So if you are getting
this value, then you'd want to create a shipping
address model or we could just create an address
model and store a field on there, which would
have a field saying his billing or his shipping,
and then you could select which ones they
are, or both of them. So there's many ways
we can handle this. For now, I'm also going
to leave that commented out and just work
with a billing address. And then here, after
we save the order, what I'm going to do say
to do add a redirect to the selected payment
option, which is something that we'll handle
in the next video. So in the last one, we
ended off with our checkout view, we can go
Proceed to Checkout. And we worked on this
form and many of the styling and handling
the submission of this data. And we didn't
touch anything to do with this kind of promo
code and displaying the items that are in
the cart. And we will get to that in a separate
video where we'll talk about promotion codes,
or discount codes and how to create those.
But in this one, we're going to continue with
the payment method that was based on what
you selected here in the form that you submitted.
And we can view that view which is in core
views, and that should be here in the checkout
view. Once we submit the post request, we
then get all that data and some of the fields
we weren't addressing yet, but one of them
is the payment option, which is something
that we need to do here. Hence, we added this
to do which is to add a redirect to the selected
payment option view where we'll handle taking
in that payment from the user. And so I'm
just going to make another class based view
which will also inherit from the generic view.
And I'll just create it here, we'll say this
is the payment view. And that's just going
to inherit from the default view, I'll say
define get takes in self ogs keyword dogs.
And I'll just say return a render of self
dot request. And we'll say this is to payment,
let's say payment dot html. And I'll bring
that into the URLs. And then I'll say that
the path goes to payment, I'll say payment
viewed as view and say name is payment. And
I'm also going to pass in kind of like a slug,
which will be the slug of the payment option
that was selected. So I'll just put your payment
option. And that could either be stripe or
PayPal. And then here in the templates, we're
going to need to create payment or HTML. And
I'm going to take everything from the checkout,
just paste it in there. And there's a lot
that we also don't really need. So all I'm
looking for is this kind of container. And
I'll say this is payment, then we have the
row. And we've got these two columns, I'm
just going to get rid of that second column
there. And in this first column, I'll say
it's column medium 12. And then we have this
card, I'll keep that form that we'll use.
But the second form I'm going to get rid of,
and then I'll uncomment this year. And actually,
I'm going to specify the class to have that
card body like the other one. So if we go
to slash, payment, slash stripe, right, and
we obviously don't have any form that's in
our context variables. And I'll just say this
is submit. But this entire form is actually
going to be handled by stripe. So I'm going
to go search for the stripe docs. And I'm
going to look for charges. And we'll see you're
creating charges. And we should be able to
see a form. And if we look for stripe j s
and elements and scroll down, then this form
here, I'm just going to inspect and actually
not just bring us open a little bit. And so
we're basically looking for where this iframe
starts, which you can see is right there.
And if you copy that entire HTML element,
you can come inside here and actually pretty
much remove that entire form and you get a
whole bunch of stuff. We get these iframes
and I'm just gonna go down here. We'll get
rid of pretty much all the iframes the body
the HTML, and we have this entire script tag
as well, that I'll cut out, put a tear at
the bottom. And then we have the form, I'm
just going to tab that in, so it's looking
a little bit better, then the script has to
stay there as well. And then the div wrapper,
I'm actually going to remove and add ends
here after the success token, which I'm also
going to remove. So we just have that. And
then we've got the head tag, I'm going to
remove and this entire style tag, and a cut
that out. And all of this inside the script,
I'm going to delete that gonna delete that
and the body tag. So everything's inside this
card, and then just come up top here, and
we'll create a block. And we'll just say this
is the head links. And I'll paste all the
style in there. And if we take a look back
here at base, that HTML, let's just see if
we have that block. And okay, that's extra
head. So just change that name. Okay, I'm
going to get rid of crispy forms, tags. And
we'll get rid of the body and HTML styles
there. Okay, so now we'll have a form generated
by stripe. So if we come back here, I'm going
to change this to be the stripe form row.
And if we just come up here, we can get rid
of the stripe token handler, and token handler
hidden and the rapper as well as the token,
so dot token, get rid of that. I'm gonna say
this is stripe perform row. So let's come
back and refresh this. And Alright, it looks
a bit better. And I'll change this to an ID
of stripe form. So that if we come back here,
this can be striped form. And instead of this
being label, I'm going to make this the stripe
button label as an ID, then we can come down.
And I'll change this label to have an ID of
stripe button label. And then for the button,
I'm going to make this the stripe button and
come down here to the button, I'll give it
an ID of stripe button. And we most likely
would want to see the audit total like we
do here in this view. So what I'll do is actually
just grab this HTML, and then we'll display
the form here to make the payment. So let's
just go back here to check out. So I'll make
this back to column eight. And so let's just
get rid of some of these. Okay, then we can
close that one. And we basically just want
this entire column. Cool. So if we come back,
and let's go to payment slash stripe. Okay,
let's just see why this isn't showing in the
right way. So we've got that div there. There's
the form. And it looks like we have one too
many divs there. Let's come back. All right,
there we go. And I'm just going to minimize
that. And let's open this app. And I'm thinking
we can get rid of the promo code, but here.
And what we'll do is, we'll make this one
column that spans the entire width and just
display it on top of each other. Because the
spacing is quite weird. So let's just come
up here. And I'm going to make this column
12 and column 12. There we go. And this looks
fine. So now we need to just handle what happens
when you submit this payment. And if we inspect
this, we are getting this add event listener,
add this line and that's coming from line
319 when we're trying to add an event listener
to the form. So that's coming down here to
get the element by ID of payment form. And
we did change that to the the stripe form.
So we got to come down here and change this
to stripe form. Then we're done. Have this
stripe token handler, we can get rid of that
can get rid of that as well. Cool. So that
seems to be everything. Let's just refresh
this now. And, okay, we've got payment form
there as well. try this again. And okay, cool.
So now we need to go back here to the form
and make sure that when we submit the form,
that it's posting this request to the right
URL, which is just going to be a dot. And
that way, when we submit this, it'll post
it to this URL. So we can go here to the view.
And we can define a POST method to handle
that request. So this will be self ogs, and
keyword dogs. And then we can actually go
and search for the stripe API, which is.com
slash Doc's slash API, then I'm just going
to go here to charges. And then to create
a charge, we're going to need to bring all
of this in. And I'm just going to paste this
here at the top. And instead of outputting,
that I'm going to say this comes from settings.
So I'm going to say from Django con, import
settings, and this will be the stripe test
key, or sorry, secret key, then we can take
this charge, come down, and we'll just paste
that over here. And we're going to need to
make sure we get the token which is coming
from the request. So this will be token equals
self dot request dot post, dot get. And that's
going to be that value that we add here in
stripe j s. So if you scroll down the stripe
token, that's the value we want to get as
the token. And then we can just paste the
token there. And I'll change this to USD.
And the amount will be the amount of the current
order. So the order we're going to pass here
into the context. So I'll just say order there.
And here, I'll also say that the order equals
to order object start get where user equals
self dot request dot user, and we ordered
equals false, so we get the current order.
And we're going to want to get the total from
that, because that's how we're going to pass
the amount in. So that's going to be order
dot get total. And then we have to say times
by 100, because this value is in cents. So
if it's $20. And we need to times by 100.
So it's 2000 cents. And the description, I'm
actually just going to get rid of that now
there's a bit of logic that we need to think
about here. When we actually receive this
post request. Not only do we need to create
the charge, but now we need to say that the
order has been ordered. So we're going to
have to change some of the values on the order
model. So we'll say here, that order dot ordered
equals to true. And then we're also going
to want to keep track of the payments. Because
right now, there's no way that we're keeping
track of the actual stripe payment. And that's
very important. So we're going to create its
own class for that. So we'll come down here
and say that this is a payment class, which
comes from models that model. And I'm going
to specify the stripe charge ID as a character
field. And I'll make this a maximum length
of let's just say 30. Or rather 50. To be
safe. I'll pass a user, which will be a foreign
key to the user model. So that's just going
to be settings dot auth user model. And on
delete, I'm going to say equals two models
dot set. No. And this is just so that we definitely
do not delete the payment if the user was
deleted. And I'll just say blank, and Nola
true for that. I'll say an amount equals two
models dot float field. And we'll add a timestamp.
And say this is models that date time field.
And I'll say auto Now, add equals true. And
then we can say define string of self. And
I'm just going to say return self dot user
dot username. And then this payment, we're
also going to under specify, like we did with
the billing address here on the order. So
I'm actually just going to copy that entire
line there. And this is going to be the payment
which is going to be a foreign key with the
payment model that we just created. And I'll
leave all of this the same. So now here when
we said ordered, ordered equals true, we also
want to create this payment. And then we're
going to assign the payment to the order.
So first, let's just save this. And we can
also see no module named stripe. So I'm going
to say pip install stripe. And then I'll say
PIP freeze into requirements dot txt. And
then I'll run Python managed.py make migrations.
Cool, then I'll say, migrate. And then we
can run the server. Alright, so now we're
going to create the payment. So I'm going
to need to go to the top here and import that
model. So that's the payment model. And then
we can go back down. So here, we'll say that
the payment equals to a payment, we'll say
that the payment stripe charge ID is going
to be equal to the ID we get back from this
creation here. So I'm going to say that charge
equals to that API call. And then I'll come
here and say charge.id, or we can access it
like this. Then I'll say payment dot user
equals self dot request dot user, I'll say
payment dot amount, equals to this here, and
I'm actually just going to specify her mt
as its own variable, then then we can just
say payment dot save. So now we have the payment,
then we can assign the payment to the order.
So I'll actually bring that here as well.
And then we can say order dot payment equals
payment. And then say order dot save. And
we're also going to want to do some error
handling here for this API call because the
card could fail and all the other types of
errors. So you're gonna want to just search
here for stripe error handling. And we can
just go to this first one handling errors.
And then I'm going to select Python as the
language. And I'm actually just going to copy
all of that. And we can come in here. And
I'm just going to create some space, paste
the soul here, and we can tab that in. So
we're going to try use stripes library, and
I'm going to have to tab some stuff in here
as well. Okay, so we're going to try and do
the charge, which is what we'll do here. And
if we get a code error, then it's declined.
So what they're doing is getting this message.
And I'm going to basically do exactly the
same thing. So they're saying error equals
body, dot get error. And I'm going to cut
that out. And we can remove all of this. And
I'm going to say messages, dot error, from
self dot request, and pass an F string, and
just paste all of this in there, just like
that, then then you can handle the exceptions
for the rest of these. So that being API connection,
a stripe error, or just a general exception.
And this is kind of the main one, because
this means it's something to do with you.
So here, I would say we send an email to ourselves.
Because this means you need to go and fix
something in the code. And the rest of these,
I'm basically just going to return an error
as a message and just paste them all here.
And get rid of all those past statements.
And then they'll just say, rate limit error.
And here I'll say, invalid parameters. I'll
say not authenticated, and then we can do
network error. And then this last one for
generic stripe error could just be something
went wrong. And they'll say, you were not
charged. Please try again. And then on this
last one here. I'll say that this is a serious
error occurred. We have been notified, something
like that. And then all of this here. We're
going to cut that out and bring that into
the try statement as well. So just like this
So after we save the order, then we're going
to redirect them back to some page. And this
would probably be like a profile page or confirmed
order page. And I'm just going to say return
redirect to let's just say slash. And I'll
say messages dot success, parsing self dot
request, and we'll say your order was successful.
And then we're also going to want to redirect
if these errors happen as well. So I'm just
going to add a redirect for all of them. So
what we should see happen is, when we test
this, now we're going to create a charge,
we should see that the payment is created.
And we should see these parameters on the
audit changed as well. And then the redirect
should be like the final confirmation that
it worked. So we'll come back in here, let's
just refresh the page. And you can use stripes
test card for payments, which is just four
to four to four times, and then make sure
that the rest of the numbers have an expiration
date in the future. So now, if we submit the
payment, Now, of course, we are getting a
CSRF error. So let's just add that in here
in the form. Okay, I'll just have to refresh
the page. Try again, we're getting an invalid
parameters error. And this could be because
we're not creating an integer value for the
amount. So we need to make sure that we do
that. And actually, this order dot get total
is the amount here that we should be saving
on the payment. So I'm going to make sure
we put that there. So servers running and
let's go back to the cart, go to checkout.
And okay, we're going to need to go to payment
stripe. Okay, now submit the payment. There
we go. Order was now successful. So let's
go into the admin. And we're going to need
to bring our payment model here. So just import
that there. Cool. Let's refresh this. Go to
payments, admin. There's the stripe charge
ID, there's the amount in dollars. And let's
go back to orders. admin receive is the item,
it's now ordered. And there's the payment.
So now the payment is working. And we just
need to now make sure that when we submit
the checkout form, so if I just add something,
then now when we submit this form, and I select
stripe, we need to make sure that here in
the view, and scroll up, we can then redirect
based on the value of the payment option.
And so instead of redirecting to core Checkout,
what we're going to do is check for the value
of the payment option. So we'll say if the
payment option equals s, and there are much
better ways to do this. But for simplicity,
we'll just keep it like this. So we'll say
redirect to core payment. And then we need
to pass in the payment option as the value
in the URL. So this and that's going to be
equal to stripe. And we'll say, else if payment
option equals to p, then it's going to go
to paypal. So we'll say redirect to paypal.
And then we'll say else, we'll show the message
and return a redirect back to checkout and
just say invalid payment option selected.
So all of that is working. We'll come here
and just submit anything in here, and we'll
select stripe, click Continue. And we get
redirected to the stripe payment form. And
now let's display this order here. So we can
go back to the other view the payment view.
And here we're going to say that this order
equals that exact call there. And then we'll
say context equals to this dictionary and
I'll just say orders order and pass the context
in there. Cool. Then back here, we're going
to need to display some of them information.
So here, this number three, this is going
to be ordered on items count. And then we
have Have a list item of the product name,
and it's going through three times there.
So I'm going to get rid of that. And we'll
say for item in order dot items, dot all.
And then say in for. And in here, we'll say,
this is the item and double check the models
here. So let's just go back. So we're referencing
the order items. So this should rather be
called Order Item. And then we can say Order
Item dot item, dot title. And then this will
be the description. So item dot description.
And then this will be, I would say, the total
price of that item. So if we come back here
to the order item, we can say get final price.
So this will be Order Item, dot get final
price. And let's save that. And lastly, let's
output the order total. So if we come back
here, that's going to be order dot get total.
Cool. Let's refresh this. Cool. So we have
dummy item too. But I think it would be cooler
if we had something like two times dummy item
two so that you know that you're ordering
to have that item. So let's just go here to
the item title. And we'll say Order Item dot
quantity. And then just say x like that, course
night and say, now you can see three times
dummy item two, which is giving you 600. And
you only have one item in your cart. So this
seems to be pretty good. So far, we haven't
covered the PayPal payment method, because
there's still a bunch of other things that
we want to cover in this course. So for the
time being, we're just going to leave it at
having stripe as the only payment option.
But it seems like everything is coming together.
And in the next one, we can go back to this
checkout view. And we'll start handling promotional
codes or discount codes. And actually, just
as a last check, let's just go back here to
the admin. And we're going to look here at
the orders, because now we have a new order.
And then you can see the billing address was
added to our user. So in this one, we're going
to focus on adding discount codes to our checkout
process, I'm just going to log in here, so
we can see where that's coming through, we
can just go to the cart, proceed to checkout.
And here it is. And there's one or two things
that we also need to fix up. First, it's here,
if we just go to the home view, the list items
of these products, they have the same image.
And that's because we don't actually have
an image field on our model at the moment.
So let's just go up top to this item. And
I'm going to add models dot image field, which
will be the image for that product. And we're
going to need to run pip install pillow so
that we can do this. Cool, then I'll just
say PIP freeze into requirements. And then
we can run the server. Cool. So now, instead
of rendering out this static image, we can
then go and output the image itself on the
model. So I'm going to home dot html. And
we can just go here to this image, just going
to comment that out. And I'm going to create
an image tag. And we're going to need a source,
which is just going to be item dot, and this
is image. So item dot image URL. And then
I'm going to use the same class here. So just
like this, and then I'm going to take this
URL, and I'm just going to download the image,
then I can close this. And we're going to
go into the admin. And I'll go to the items.
And right we didn't make migrations. So we
can say manage that py make migrations. And
I'm just going to quit here so that we can
add blank and null or true. Then I'll make
migrations again. And then we could say migrate.
Cool. Now we can run the server. Then we can
go back here to the admin. And I'm just going
to go to both items here and choose an image.
Okay, now both of them have images and I'm
going to go here and remove blank and null
as true and make migrations and I'm going
to say ignore Now and migrates again. There
we go, then we can run the server. Cool. So
now let's go to the home view. And they aren't
outputting. And that's because the folder
we've specified here for the media route is
inheriting from the virtual environment path.
And I'm going to change this to the base directory.
And same thing for static route. And I'll
get rid of that. I'll change this to media
route. And now I just moved the media directory
back inside here, because it was one folder
outside the project. And then I'm just going
to make sure that this is renamed media route.
So now let's go back, refresh this. And let's
just make sure that we get rid of that as
well. Okay, and they still aren't displaying.
So let's just inspect here. And if we grab
that URL, paste that they see media is not
actually a URL. So we're going to need to
go inside URLs here. I'm just going to go
here to the top and just say from Django dot
con, dot URLs, dot static, import static.
And I'm going to add a static URL to Settings
dot media URL, and say document route equals
settings dot media route. Okay, let's go back
and refresh this now. There it is. And let's
go back. Okay, now that's displaying. I'm
also going to paste this, and we'll change
this one to static URL. And that's the static
route. Okay, cool. Now, if we go here to the
cart, you can see that we have this item in
the cart, I'm going to go and open up the
admin as well as we can see this in action.
And I'm going to go to the orders. And actually
one way of helping us distinguish which orders
are which, let's just go into the core admin.
And here, I'm going to say that this is the
order admin. And it's going to come from admin,
dot model admin. And I'll just say that the
list display equals two, and just get the
model here. So we have user, and then I'm
also going to display the ordered field like
this, then I'm just going to bring this in
like that. Let's come back. Okay, there we
go. So now we know which ones are ordered
or not. So I'm going to go to the unordered.
One. And we see that we have this item in
the order. And so let's go and proceed to
checkout. And just put in anything here, and
we'll select stripe, continue to checkout,
then just add a credit card and say submit
payment. Okay, now to successful, so we don't
have anything in the cart. That's correct.
But if we go back here to orders, that one
is now ordered. And it shows that that item
is there. And it was the $200 item. So if
I come back here and add this to cart, you
can see again, it still has that same price,
the same quantity, which means it's the same
order item. So all we need to do is go on
to our order item. And here we have the ordered
field. And we weren't changing this value
last time when we were submitting the payment.
So let's just go here to the view. And here
when we were saving the order, we were saying
ordered or ordered equals true. And we needed
to do the same thing for all of the items
in the order. So what I'm going to do here
is just say that the order items equals to
order dot items, dot all. And because we have
a query set, and we want to update all of
these items, we can simply just call the update
method on the query set. So we can say, order
items dot update. And the field that we want
to update is the ordered field. And we want
to set it equal to true. But then we need
to loop through all of these order items and
save each order item as well. So we're going
to say for item in order items. Just call
item dot save and like this, we can then go
and test this So let's go and add this to
cart. There it is. Proceed to Checkout, continue
to checkout, submit payment. Now let's go
here to the orders. There's that third order,
and we see ordered is true. Go to order items.
Now we can see that order item has been ordered.
So if we come here and go to the same item
and add to cart, now we see that it's adding
exactly one unique item. And that means we
can go back here. And now we have a new order
item. Cool. So that is fixed. And now we can
look at creating discount codes. So what I'm
going to do is in this models.py file, we're
going to create a new class. And this is going
to be, let's say a coupon comes from models
dot model. And I'll just say that the code
is a character field. And we'll say that the
maximum length is 15 characters, and then
just say define string of self. And we'll
say return self dot code. And we can bring
this into the admin as well. And we're going
to need to run, make migrations and then just
say migrate. And then we can run the server.
And so here, we can go back to coupons and
add a coupon. And this is just going to be
any code. So let's say first timer, just save
that. And then if we go here to the cart,
and proceed to checkout, then here in this
form, we're going to enter that value, we're
going to create a view that will handle taking
in that code, check if the code exists. If
it does, and the user hasn't used it already.
And we could do some other things to see like,
does the coupon that the order has already
give a higher percentage discount than the
one you're trying to add, we're not going
to add something like that. But that's some
ideas that you could get creative with. And
then just do basic validation, to add it onto
the cart. So let's come back here, and we'll
go to the View, we'll come all the way down.
And we're going to create a new view, and
this is going to be add coupon, which will
just take in a request and a code. And so
we're going to want to get the user's order.
So let's get all of this here. So we could
actually just call dot get. And what we'll
do is we'll just put it in our try statement.
And we'll just say except the object does
not exist, which we already have imported
from the top here. So if the object does not
exist, then we'll just return a redirect.
And we could say that this goes to, let's
say, core order summary. Or rather Checkout,
and will display a message and just say, you
do not have an active order, which is fine.
So if we do have that order, then we're going
to check that the coupon code exists. So let's
go to the top and import the coupon. There
it is. And then here, we'll say that the coupon
equals to coupon dot objects dot get where
code equals to code. And we're also catching
the exception here. But let's just define
a shortcut method here. And we'll just say,
this is get coupon just takes a code. And
we'll do the same thing here. But we could
wrap it in a try statement, and just paste
that right there. And if it doesn't exist,
then we'll just say, this also takes in a
request maybe, and we'll say, this coupon
does not exist. And then here, we can say
a coupon equals to get coupon where the request
is the request, and the code is a code we're
being passed in here. And then here, we just
need to make sure to return that coupon. So
now we have the coupon. And then we want to
somehow assign this coupon to the order. So
again, on the order, we're going to need to
create a foreign key field to the coupon.
So we'll say coupon equals models dot foreign
key to the coupon and all of this same stuff
and we're going to need to Make migrations
for that. So make migrations and migrate,
run the server. So now, we can then assign
this coupon to the order. So we can say order
coupon equals two, we could actually just
do like this get coupon. And then we say order
dot Save, and then return a redirect back
to checkout. And we'll just put a success
message. And we'll say, successfully added
coupon. We're also not doing any kind of validation
right now, in terms of how many times this
coupon has been used. Or if you've used this
coupon before, as well, those are some things
that we need to take into consideration. But
for now, let's just take this add coupon and
bring it into our URLs. And here, I'll just
copy that and say this is add coupon. And
we'll put code in there. And then just say
this name of the URL is add coupon like that.
So now we have a URL, and back inside the
order summary dot html, we can then go down
to that form. And then down in the checkout
dot html, we should have this form here. And
this exact column medium four is the exact
same thing that we used in the payment dot
html. If we just come up here, you can see
there, I'm going to get rid of that comment
there. So what I'm going to do is I'm going
to cut that out. And I'm going to create a
snippet. And we'll just say that this is the
order snippet dot html. And I'm just going
to paste all of this. And then we can just
bring this in a little bit. So we need to
make sure that we are passing an order into
this order snippet. And we'll also need to
pass any coupon codes that we've added, we'll
worry about this in a second. Let's just come
back here. And we'll say include the order
snippet dot html. And because this used to
be here, we don't need to use the width keyword.
So if we come back and refresh this, and this
is the wrong view, let's just go here to payment,
and stripe. Cool. So you can see that that's
still working. So now we want that exact same
thing to be used here. So inside Checkout,
we can pretty much remove the entire column,
except we want to make sure that we keep this
form. So I'm going to cut it out and bring
it into the order snippet. And we'll just
paste it right here. And it actually goes
inside this div. So like this. But now if
we were to come back and just refresh this
now you can see that we have promo code here.
And if we don't want to display it here, we
can put in some logic to do that as well.
But we'll just leave it for now. So back inside
Checkout, we can then go and remove the entire
div. So this here, everything inside there.
Just delete all of this, and say include the
order snippet dot html, then let's go back,
refresh this. And there it is, we obviously
aren't bringing the order into this order
snippet. And if we check here, for any context
variables, we can see we only have a form
displaying and a lot of comments, so I'm going
to clean this up as well. Okay, that's much
better. So we need to make sure that we bring
the order into the checkout view. And if we
scroll up, then here is the checkout view.
And so here in the get, we're going to want
to pass in the order. So let's just put order
like this. And we'll use the same logic we
did down here. To try and get the order. I'm
just going to copy all of that. Come up top
here and use a try again. So we're getting
the order and then we don't need the coupon
or any of that. And this is self dot request
dot user. And then say self dot, actually,
we don't need that message. And we don't need
that return there either. We can basically
just cut that out, put them inside the try
statement. And make sure that this is self
dot request. And then the order is that order.
So we're trying to get the order, if the order
doesn't exist, then we will return the exact
same redirect to the checkout view and just
display the message. Otherwise, we're passing
in the form and the order into the context.
So now if we come back, and let's just see,
run the server and refresh this. And there's
our order coming through now. So let's now
go to the audit snippet. And we're going to
deal with this form. Now, we need to make
sure that when we submit this form, that it
gets posted to the correct URL. And actually,
instead of doing it, how we have it here,
I'm going to remove this code there. And back
inside the view, I'm gonna remove that code
as well, I'm going to create a form. And this
is going to be the coupon form, which will
just be forms dot form. And all it takes is
a code, which is going to be a character field.
And if we take a look at the snippet, we need
to make sure that the input has a class of
form control. So let's take all of that, come
here. And we'll say widget equals forms that
text input and say attributes where the class
is form control, and the placeholder is promo
code. And then we can also add the two fields
here. Okay, so all of that, then we can bring
this coupon into the views. So from dot forms,
import coupon form. And then all the way down
here. We're gonna say if request, dot method
equals post, all say form equals coupon form,
with request dot post, or none. And then say,
if form.is valid, then we will do all of this,
let's just get rid of that. And otherwise,
we'll return some kind of air, I'm just going
to return none there for now. And I'll just
put to do res error. So we're only accepting
POST requests. And then here, in the try statement,
we'll say that the code equals to form that
cleaned data dot get the code so that we can
then pass it into the get coupon. And yes,
you could also validate this on the form,
there's many ways you can do this. And so
then here, instead of outputting, the input
like this, I'm going to comment it out. And
here, I'm going to say, form. And back here
inside the view, we'll go up to that checkout
view up top here, I'll add coupon form as
the coupon form, like this, and then just
come back here. And let's change this to coupon
form. And I'm going to access DOD code, because
that's the only field there. So now, if we
come back and refresh this, that still seems
to be working, let's just inspect here. And
we can see that the name equals code. So that's
looking good. And then here, the type button,
I'm going to change to type submit, and also
add the CSRF token. And we need to also add
the action, which is going to go to that URL.
So it's going to be URL to core. And this
is going to be add coupon to a posting to
the Add coupon URL. Let's come back and refresh
this now. And if we take a look here, we have
first timer. So if we submit first timer,
let's just come back into the view and double
check what's going to happen. So it's going
to get the code, we're going to check for
the order. We're going to get the coupon,
save it to the order, and then we'll see successfully
added coupon. And it'll redirect us back to
this checkout. So let's redeem. And we're
getting this didn't return HTTP, which means
that we didn't specify method equals post.
So it was sending a get request. And let's
come back and refresh this. Just get rid of
all of that. Go to proceed to checkout Add
first timer redeem their successfully added
coupon. Now if we go back to the order, go
to that last order, there we can see the coupon
is attached. And now we want to add a method
that will subtract the amount that the coupon
gives a discount for. So let's go back here
to the model. And here on the order in the
get total method, after we loop through all
the items, we're going to subtract the value
on the coupon. So if we come back here, we
need an amount on the coupon. So that's going
to be a float field. And then the amount here,
we will say, total minus equals two. And it's
going to be self dot coupon, dot amount. And
then we're going to need to make migrations.
So I'm going to provide a default. And let's
just say that this is 20. And then we can
migrate, run the server. So if we come back
here, now the total is 180. And the promo
code, we're going to display the name of it,
and then the amount over there. So let's go
back to order snippet. So now since the coupon
is attached to the order, we can access it
via that order. So I'm just going to say order
dot coupon, because of the foreign key. And
this is going to be code. And then for this
$5, we'll replace that with ordered coupon
amount. And there we see first timer we see
minus 20. And there's the 180 total. So all
of that looking good. If I go to slash payment,
slash stripe, we can see it's working here
as well. And what I'm going to do here in
this payment view, you can just go back here
to views and just scroll up here to the get
method of the payment view. I'm going to set
display, coupon form as false. And then I'm
going to copy that. And we're going to bring
it here into the get method of the checkout
view pasted here. And I'm going to make this
true, then inside order snippet, let's actually
grab this value, we can then say if display
coupon form. And and if. So if we come back
here, now we don't see the coupon form. This
is optional, if you want to handle it like
this. And so let's just go back here to the
cart, proceed to checkout. And okay, there
it is. And one thing that we also saw is that
we were able to go to the payment view without
completing the checkout form. So we want to
add some kind of condition that's saying something
like, if you don't have a billing address,
then you can't go to the payment view yet.
So let's go to here to the payment view. And
we're just going to check your if order dot
and we can come here to billing address. So
if audit our billing address, then we will
render out this request. And we'll say else,
then we will grab something like that. And
just say you have not added a billing address.
And we'll redirect back to checkout. So now
if we just go back here to this order, you
can see that it's not ordered yet. So we can
see we don't have a billing address here.
So that means that if I were to go to payment,
slash stripe, then it just says you have not
added a billing address. Let's just refresh
that there. And it seems messages dot error
doesn't work. So let's use warning instead.
And instead there as well. And we'll just
replace it like this. So messages dot error
with messages dot warning. There we go. And
then if we just come down here to the bottom,
we have this to do over here. And instead
of checking if the request method is a post,
I'm just going to change it into a class based
view. And we'll call it the Add coupon view.
And again, it's going to take in a view and
then we'll just say define the post request,
which takes ogs and keyword dogs, and then
we can get rid of request dot post there,
get rid of that and just pass in self dot
request instead of request. And then we can
just make sure that our URL uses this correctly.
So we say.as view and change the input there
as well run the server and a little spelling
error there. Okay, cool. So now we won't be
able to send a get request to this view. And
we also won't be able to go to the payment
view without having a billing address first.
So let's try and complete the process and
make sure that everything's working. And we
most likely also would want to show the discount
here in the order summary. So we got up to
the order summary view, which is here, we're
already passing in the order. So that means
that we can display the coupon if there is
one. So let's open up the templates, we'll
go to order summary. And if we scroll down,
here we have if ordered dot get total, then
we're displaying the total. So what I'm going
to do is add another condition and say if
order dot coupon, then we'll display another
row as well and just say endif. So I'll copy
that row there. And I'll say, coupon. and
the value will be object, dot coupon, dot
amount. And I'm also going to change that
to object dot coupon. So if we come here and
refresh this, now we have coupon there. And
I'll also put a negative in front of that.
Cool. So that's displaying there, proceed
to checkout. And we'll just add an address
here. Select the country, select stripe and
just enter the stripe card number, submit
payment. Order was successful. Let's go here,
refresh it, there's the billing address and
the payment, it's now been ordered. And let's
go check the payment value. And the amount
is 180. So everything seems to be working
pretty well. So in this video, we're going
to be focusing on creating kind of like an
order management system. And this is to help
us kind of understand where all of our orders
are in their phases. And an example of that
would be keeping track of the number of orders
that have been abandoned. And how many of
them have been delivered, how many of them
have been paid, received, etc. So we're going
to add a whole bunch of statuses here on our
order model. And that's going to help us keep
track of those. So I'm just going to come
here and add a couple more fields. And this
is going to represent kind of like the lifecycle
of an order. Now, I'm actually just going
to add it as a comment. Firstly, so we can
brainstorm this. So the first phase would
be when the order is created, this is when
someone actually adds an item to their cart.
And that is the beginning of the order. So
that is we'll just say item added to cart.
Then the second phase, we also saw this in
our checkout process, if we just log in here
to demonstrate. If I come here and add something
to the cart, and we're getting this none type
object has no amount. Let's just see here.
This is total minus equals self dot coupon
dot amount, which is in my 95. So this is
over here. And we should actually just add
a condition to check if there is a coupon.
So we'll say if self dot coupon, then we'll
subtract that amount. And now let's go and
try this again. There we go to get rid of
one there. So this is the first step, we've
added an item to the cart. Now if we proceed
to checkout, we would fill in this form and
it would add the billing address to the order.
And that is the second phase. So adding a
billing address, then we know that if we fill
this in, and I'm just going to put something
in there, select stripe continue. We know
that this is the third phase, and oh, we're
getting a promo code thing there. But there
is no promo code. So let's go fix that as
well. So inside templates, and this is payment,
and it's included in the order snippet. So
here, I'm just going to add if order a coupon.
And and if I can, let's try that now. There
we go. So here, we would fill in the payment.
And let's do that, and then submit the payment.
And I'm getting not authenticated, that means
that I don't have my stripe keys in. So I'm
going to go add that. So let me go and try
checkout again. And that could actually be
another status that we add here in the model,
which is a failed transaction. And this is
actually something you can listen for with
stripe web hooks. So I'm going to put your
failed checkout. And this could be due to
many reasons which we saw we covered in the
exceptions. So we could keep track of how
many of each exception has occurred. And you'd
most likely be more concerned with the errors
that are due to your part not due to stripes
API, for example, receiving too many requests,
you'd rather be focused on why your code didn't
work. And hopefully, that doesn't happen too
many times. So let's go proceed and continue
submit payment, cool order was successful.
And let's open up the admin. Go to the order.
There's that last one. And so that confirms
the third process, which is payment, then,
once it has been bought, because this is ecommerce
means we actually have to deliver that item
that they've bought to their address. So depending
on whatever business processes you have, there's
a lot that could be put in here, such as something
like pre packaging, packaging, processing,
and the whole supply chain movement there.
And we could add this in house or something
like pre processing, processing, packaging,
etc. And I think the most important takeaway
from that is when it's ready to be delivered,
or is being delivered. So basically just keeping
track of the orders that are on the road.
So we'll say being delivered as a status of
the order. And then logically from there,
once it's on the road, and it's heading towards
the customer, the next step is to note when
it's been received. And if you're using DHL,
or FedEx or whoever you're using to deliver
that. Normally, you do have some process with
the person who's receiving it has to sign
it off and say that they've actually received
this item. And you'll want to keep track of
that in whichever system that is that you're
using, and link that to here. So once it has
been received, you can then confirm that it
has been received here. And this may seem
like the last step, but we actually will need
to keep track of the number of refunds. And
this is actually the last step, because there's
no way it can go after it's being refunded.
So we definitely do want to make sure we keep
track of this because it does happen, people
asked for refunds. And we want to make sure
that we have functionality to handle that.
So what we're going to do is add these three
statuses here on the model, and they're just
going to be Boolean fields. And by default,
it's going to be false like the ordered field.
So I'm just going to paste that there. So
the first one here will be being delivered,
and by default is false, then we have received,
and how we'll handle refunds is just by adding
two statuses here. And this is going to be
refund requested. So that means someone has
actually either sent an email or completed
a form explaining why they are requesting
the refund. And then we would have refund,
granted. So there would also be this Boolean
field. And you could keep track of the number
of refunds rejected. But if you have these
two already, then you don't really need to.
So the whole point of this is so that you
can keep track of what has been processed
in terms of refunds and what hasn't, and still
needs to be processed. So once something has
been granted a refund, then it's kind of moved
over to a separate pile, you don't need to
worry about that anymore. But the refund requests
that is an important field that we should
monitor. So with all of these statuses added,
we're going to make migrations. And we're
then going to add some stuff here in the admin
to help us manage all of these fields. So
we'll say Python managed.py, make migrations,
then we can say migrate. And then I'll go
and run the server. And so we have our order
here inside the admin and we already started
creating our own custom order admin. And we're
going to build on top of this now. So let's
come back inside here, and start off here
with the list view or list to display and
we're going to add Whole bunch of these fields
into the list display. So let's take a look
here back at the fields that we've added.
And that is being delivered, received, refund
requested and refund granted. And we're going
to add all of them in here. So just like this.
Now, let's come back in here and refresh this.
And this kind of gives you an idea of the
whole workflow. It's ordered, hasn't been
delivered. And again, you could add in pre
processing, packaging, etc, being delivered,
received, refunds requested and refund granted.
And so we'll customize the admin to allow
to filter by these fields. And there's one
more important field that we definitely need
to add on to these orders. And that's a reference
code. Because without a reference code, there's
no way for the user to actually communicate
on which order it is, we're going to get to
that in a second, but let's just customize
the admin here. So back inside, here, we have
the list display. Next is going to be the
list filter, which is also going to be a list
of fields. And I'm basically just going to
copy all of these, I can come back in here
and refresh this. And now you can see the
filter here on the right hand side. So you
can filter them for which have been ordered,
which have been delivered, and etc. So what
I'm going to do is copy these three, we're
going to go back in the admin. And we're going
to add the list display links, which is also
a list of fields, we're going to add that
and we're also going to add the user. Now
we get some errors, because these fields are
not inside our list display, so we need to
add them in here as well. So I'll add it.
Okay, cool. Now, let's come back in Yeah,
this just allows us to navigate to these billing
addresses, and the payments, all from this
one view. And so now let's go and add the
reference code. So let's just add it here
at the top. And this is going to be a character
field, I'll say maximum length is, let's say
30. Or, actually, let's go with 20. And then
we can go and make migrations, we'll add a
default and just say 123. And then we can
migrate, run the server again. And so here
inside our views, we're going to add a function
that will create that reference code. And
the moment we create the reference code is
once the order has been purchased. So that's
going to be here in this payment view. So
if we come a little bit down here inside the
try statement, when we assign the payment
here, we're going to assign the reference
code. And I'm just going to go all the way
to the top of this file here. I'm going to
say define create reference code, which doesn't
take any arguments. And here we're going to
need random and we're going to need the string
package as well. So I'm going to say import
random and import string. And then here, we're
going to say return an empty string. And I'm
going to say dot join on random dot choices.
And here we pass in a list of choices. And
this is just going to be string dot ASC II,
lowercase. And I'm going to add string dot
digits. So that's just going to create a random
sequence of characters. And then I'm going
to pass in K, which is a special argument
for the length of the string, which I'm going
to say is 20. And then we'll bring this method
down here to our to do, and I'll say order
dot reference code equals create reference
code. So now we're going to go and test this
out. So I'll come and add this item to the
cart, Proceed to Checkout, continue, and submit
payment. Now let's go back here, refresh this,
we have a new order course. So there's the
reference code, we can see there. And we'll
design a simple profile view that shows you
all of your orders so that you can at least
see the reference code as well. And then that
way, when you want to ask for a refund, you
can reference that code and we know what you're
talking about. So back here in the admin,
we're going to want to add a search field
here. And this is search fields actually,
which is a list of fields that we can search
by, I'm going to add the user so that we can
search by user. And I'm going to add reference
code so we can search by reference code. And
these are really the only two fields that
we should be searching for. So like this,
we come back into the admin and just go back
to the list display. Now we have a search
field And if I go back here, and we searched
by this reference code, and we're getting
related field got invalid lookup. So here,
I'm going to change this to use a user name.
And if you search for it, now it works. So
we weren't searching a field, we were searching
an object. And I'm not going to display the
reference code here. Because it doesn't really
provide you with any value, you should just
be able to rely on the search. And then if
you click here, then at least you can verify
that it has that reference code. So now we
can at least see and work with our orders
in a much better way. And we can go and add
a form for users to fill in, so that they
can request refunds. And then what we'll do
is we will change the status of the order
to have a refund requested as true. So let's
close all of this. And all the way here at
the bottom, we're going to add a new view,
I'm going to say this is the request refund
view, which will inherit from the default
class based view, I'll say define the POST
method. And then we're going to need a form.
So here beneath the coupon form, I'll say
this is the refund form, which just comes
from forms diet. And this will just be a normal
form, I'm going to say that the reference
code equals to form start character field,
and we could add a message as a text area,
then we can take the form. And let's just
go to the top to import this, then we'll go
back down. And here we're going to say our
form equals to refund form of request or post
or say, if form that is valid, then I'm going
to grab these two fields, the reference code
and the message, we can paste them here. And
I'm going to say equals to form dot cleaned
data dot get that value. And what we could
also do is define our own refund model. And
this is just to store the refund so that we
have record of it. So we can do this very
simply, I'll just come down here. And I'll
say class, refund model stock model, I'll
specify the order, which is a foreign key
to the order and just say on the lead equals
models dot cascade, will provide the reason,
which can just be a text field, let's say,
then we'll have accepted which can just be
a Boolean field. And I'll say default, equals
false. Because when we created, it'll be when
the user has submitted that form, which means
that it obviously hasn't been accepted yet.
And then we can just say, define string of
self. And we'll say return self dot. And I'm
just going to return the primary key, but
we're going to need to put this inside an
F string, because it's an ID, it's not a not
a string. And then we can bring this refund
into the admin as well. So for there, and
we can also bring it here inside our views.
So import this model. And so we're first going
to try and get the order by this reference
code field. So we're gonna say try, order
equals to order dot objects. dot get where
the reference code equals to the reference
code. Then if we do have that order, we can
say, order dot. And let's just go back up
here. So order dot refund requested, equals
to true order dot save. And then we will store
our own custom refund. So we'll say refund
equals to a refund object, or say the order
equals to the order will say refund dot reason
equals to message and then we can save the
refund. And we actually would also want to
keep track of the email from the person who
submitted it. This is just so that we can
get in contact with them. So we'll say models
dot email field. And then here we can say
in the form that we have an email which is
an email field. And then we will get the email
just like this. And I'm going to change that
to self dot request dot post. And then here
we'll say refund dot email equals to email.
Now we need to go and make migrations. So
we'll say make migrations. And up. Let's just
finish here, what we what we started. So we'll
say accept object does not exist, we'll just
return a redirect back to that same view,
I'm just going to put slash for now. And I'm
also going to add a message and just say,
messages dot info, with self dot request.
And we'll say this order does not exist. And
that's just tablet in there. And then we can
also redirect here. And we'll say, messages
dot info. And we'll say your request was received.
And now we can try and make migrations. There
we go. Now we can migrate and run the server.
And then we can bring our refund view into
the URLs. And I'll just add another one here,
we'll say path to her request, refund, and
say this.as view. And we can say, name, equals
request, refund, then here, in our view, when
we redirect back, we can redirect back to
call request refund. And we can do the same
thing there. Cool. So now we need to go and
build this form in HTML. So let's go into
the templates, create a file there, this will
be request, refund dot html, I'm going to
go here to the order summary, I'll just copy
all of this, and we don't need a table. I'll
just put your request, refund. And then here,
we're going to create a form, I'll pass in
the CSRF token. And I'll say that the method
equals post. And I'll just output the form
here. And I'm going to say crispy. And then
here we can say load crispy forms tags. And
then I'll add a button and just say Submit.
And the type is going to be Submit. And the
class is going to be button button primary.
And then we need to link this to our view.
So here I'll say define get, which just takes
in self. And I'll just say return a render
of that request. And it's going to go to request
refund dot html, then I'm going to say the
form equals to this refund form. And we can
get rid of all of that. And we'll bring this
into our context, we'll say form is form,
and then pass the context in there. And then
just say, self dot request there. Okay. Now,
let's go to request, refund. There's our form.
And let's go back into the forms. This should
be a character field, and say widget equals
forms dot text area. refresh this, there we
go. I'm just gonna specify here that the attributes
were the rose is for just refresh that. There
we go. Alright, so if I enter just a random
thing in there, and say add to model com,
submit, this order does not exist. Cool. Now,
let's go back here. And I'm just going to
grab this reference code, paste that in there.
And say, submit, your request was received.
Come back in here, refresh this. Now we see
refund requested. And so lastly, we're going
to add our own custom action. So you see how
these are actions, we're going to create our
own custom one, so that we can select the
orders, however many we want, and then we
will update the status from requested to granted.
And you could add the same functionality then
for the rest of these, but we're just going
to demonstrate it with this one field. So
we need to go back inside the admin. So I'm
going to close all of these and just open
up the admin. And so we're going to just define
our function here above this class. And I'm
going to say that it's called make refund.
accepted. And this takes in a model admin,
a request, and the query set as arguments.
And so here, because we're passing in the
query set, this is where you can make use
of the query set dot update method. And all
you do inside this method is just specify
the field that you want to update. So in our
case, we're going to update the refund requested
field to be false, because it's no longer
requested, it's now accepted. So I'm going
to say that, and I'm going to say refund granted,
equals to true. And that's it, then we can
just add a description. So I'm going to say
make, make refund accepted dot short description,
equals to. And we can get an idea from here.
So delete selected orders, this will be update
orders to refund granted. And then we can
just take this, and we bring it into the actions,
which is a list of functions created in this
format. So now we have our own custom action,
we can refresh the page. And now you can see
here, update orders to refund granted. So
if I grab this one, select that and click
Go. Now you can see a change the status from
requested to granted. Alright, so in this
one, we are going to start working with a
default setting for our shipping and billing
addresses. So this will basically allow you
to click a checkbox, which can then save your
current billing information that you entered
into the form as your default billing address,
which you can then reuse in further checkout
processes. And the same thing for the shipping
address. And I'm just going to go and login
so we can see what we're actually talking
about. And let's just go and add something
into the cart. and proceed to checkout. And
so right now this is the checkout form, we
have some options that we can fill in for
the address. And then we can click here to
say that the shipping address is the same
as the billing address. Now we're going to
change the way that this looks a little bit
and just add like a heading here that says
that this is the shipping address part. And
then we'll have the billing address part and
add in some extra checkboxes that can allow
you to basically specify whether you want
to use them as the same address or you want
to reuse old addresses. So things like that.
So that's what we're going to do. So let's
just go and get the code here. So we're going
to call into views. And let's just install
that. And so we want to go here to the checkout
view. And here inside the post request we
had a to do, which was to add some functionality
for what we're talking about right now, which
is the whole same shipping address and saving
this information. But we're going to change
the way that this works in the models. So
a lot of this is going to change. So let's
just open up the models here as well. And
we'll just go here to the address. And let's
just see here, this is the billing address.
So right now we only have one kind of address,
which is the billing address. But what we're
going to do is change this to be just a generic
address. And then we will add a type of address
here as one of the fields. So we'll say this
is the address type, and say this is a character
field. And I'll say that the maximum length
is one and then we can add choices, which
can just be another tupple up top here. I'm
just going to copy and paste this, like that.
And we'll just call this the address choices,
then this is either going to be billing or
shipping. So we can just get rid of that last
one. And we'll call this the shipping. And
we'll call this billing. So then we can take
those and just come down and specify those
as the choices over here. Cool. So now we
have that we're just going to add one more
field and this is default. And this is going
to be a Boolean field. So we'll set default
equal to false, so that it's not a default
address. Basically what we'll do with this
field is every time you say use this as my
default billing address, or use this as my
default shipping address, will then just grab
the address you just created and then set
default to be true, which you can then select
in further purchases. So that's what this
field is going to allow us to do. But now
that we've changed the address, we're going
to need to change This here and our orders
well, because we have a foreign key to that,
that model already. So I'm going to change
this to be called address. And then we can
actually just copy the entire thing. And we'll
call this one, the shipping address. So let's
just change one of them here. But because
the foreign keys on the same model, we're
going to need to give them a related name.
So this one can be called the shipping address,
just like this. And then the same concept
here for the billing address. Cool. So now
let's try and make migrations with that. And
now we're getting an import error in our views.
So let's just go here to the top line 11.
So this is no longer billing address. And
I'm just going to search for all of those
billing addresses. And there's only one other
which is there. So we can change this to be
called address. And then for this one here,
we'll also call this one address. And when
we create a billing address, we'll just need
to come here and specify that the address
type is equal to b for billing. So let's try
and make migrations again. And there we go.
Now we can migrate. And now we're getting
an integrity error. So the easiest way to
solve this is just for us to go and delete
those migrations. So I'm going to delete that
entire folder, and then delete the database
as well. Then we can say, managed up py make
migrations, just for the core app. And then
we can say migrate, okay, also create a new
super user. And then we can run the server
call, let's go into the admin. And we'll just
import that model. So address. And here we
have billing address, we also going to add
in the shipping address. So just specify that
here. And then we'll also add it in over here
in the list display links. Okay, then we can
just copy this and register the address model.
And if we just take a look here, again, we're
just going to copy all these fields, so that
we can specify them in a custom admin model.
So we'll come here, also, this is the address
admin, which inherits from the admin dot model
admin, then we'll just say list display is
all of these fields. Okay, then we can also
add in the list filter. And we can filter
by the country, we can filter, if it's a default
address, and we can filter by the address
type. And we'll probably want to put country
at the end day because it's quite a long list.
So let's just move it there. Then we have
the search fields. And we're going to want
to search by user. And we could add all of
these fields in as well. So let's just add
them in here. So street address, the apartment
address. And we could also search by zip as
well. Okay, there we go, then we can just
take that, and make sure that we register
the admin with that model for so if we go
into the admin, and we're going to need to
log in with our new super user. There we go.
And we can also come here and change the class
meta. So let's just add class matter. And
we'll just say verbose, name, plural equals
two addresses. Okay, then that's just a refresher.
And there we go, that looks better. So we
can come in here and we can add an address
for user. And we're also going to need to
change the form now, because if we come into
the checkout form, you can see that this is
all based on having one type of address which
is the billing address. So basically, what
we want to do is duplicate all of these fields
because our form is now going to have a billing
address and a shipping address. So to make
this easier, instead of putting all of these
fields over here, we're just going to do it
in place. HTML. So let's just keep this open
and go into templates. And we can go into
checkout dot html. And just here above the
address, I'm going to add an h3 tag. And we
can just say that this is the shipping address.
That will take in first. And then what I'm
going to do is wrap all of these fields except
for one of the last ones. And we'll just wrap
it all inside a div. So all of this all the
way here to this HR, I'm just going to tab
that in, close that off in a div. And I'm
going to give it a class name. And we'll just
say that this class is the high double shipping
form. This is just so that we can get hold
of it to toggle the display from being displayed
to not being displayed depending on whether
we click a checkbox. And then I'm going to
basically copy all of this. So everything
up top beneath this HR or just above the HR,
I'm going to then paste it all again, except
this one is now the billing address. So if
we were to come back here and refresh this,
we're getting redirected to many times. So
let's just go back here. And what I'm going
to do is just come here and add in a new item,
just so we can add something to the cart.
Cool. So now we have an item. And there it
is. So we can go and visit it Add To Cart.
Here it is. And let's proceed to checkout.
Cool. So now we have shipping address, billing
address. And we've got the payment process
over here. So we can actually add that as
a heading there as well. So if we just come
down here, after the HR tag, what I'm actually
going to do is move the div to not include
that HR. And I'll do the same thing with this
wrapping div over there. So now if we come
back here, this is continue to checkout. And
here's our radio options for the payment option.
So here, I'll just add another h3 and we can
just say this is payment option. Now if we
take a look. And there we go. And we'll fix
the styling as we go along. But for now, let's
just go back here into the form. And let's
just get all of these placeholders and move
them over as inputs here in the form. Because
right now we are putting these form fields
dynamically. So what I'm going to do is just
get rid of that. And then we can come here
and specify an input, I'll set the type is
text, we can set up the placeholder is equal
to this value here. So I'll just copy and
paste that in there, we can set that the ID
is going to go to the shipping address. And
we can say that the name is also the shipping
address. And then we can say that the class
is form control, then we just make sure that
this ID is the same as that ID. And then we
will basically do the exact same thing here.
So we'll just get rid of that output there.
And I'm just going to call this shipping address
too. And then get rid of all of that and change
that as well. And then the placeholder can
be what the placeholder is over here. So apartment,
or suite, okay, then the form country, we're
going to output the way it is because that's
coming from our Django country's package.
So we'll leave it as it is. But we can actually
get rid of the widgets here now. So we'll
just get rid of all of that. And then I'm
going to add in your required equals false.
And even though it is we'll handle whether
or not we got it in the view, and then I'm
going to change the names of those as well.
So the first one is the shipping address,
then its shipping address to country, we'll
change to shipping country. And then for the
zip, we'll change this to be shipping zip
as well. And same thing, I'm going to get
rid of all of those and just add the required
equals false, then shippings up, we can come
down and here instead of this form that's
being outputted. I'll copy that and paste
that here. Then we can say that this placeholder
is let's just say so code, and then shipping
zip, we'll copy and paste as the ID and the
name and there we go. Then also change the
forward to be shipping. So as well. So if
we take a look, we just have that country
not showing up. So let's just come back here,
copy shipping country come back here, and
this is formed that shipping country. Then
if we come back and refresh this, there we
go. And I'll just fix some of the spacing
here. And so we can see that this high level
div is wrapping all of that over there. But
what I'm going to do is I'm going to cut both
of these out, and I'm going to move them inside
there as well. And then there's just tab that
like this, then I'm going to get rid of all
these if statements inside these inputs for
the checkboxes, we can keep this one as same
billing address. And I'm just going to change
the ID to be same billing address and same
billing address. And we can say here, this
is billing address is the same as my shipping
address. So like this. So that's going to
be the first checkbox, then the second checkbox
is going to be saving this as the default
shipping address. So we can just come here
and change this text and say, save as default
shipping address. And then the name, I'm going
to say as set default shipping. And we can
then just copy and paste this everywhere it
needs to be. Okay, now let's kind of refresher.
Cool. So that's looking much better. Then
there's one more checkbox, we want to add
here, which is to say, use the default billing
address. And then we could put some text that's
referencing your current default billing address.
So I'm basically just going to copy this,
come outside the high level div. And we'll
put this one here. And then say, instead of
Save as this will be use default shipping
address. And here, we could just put that,
say, some address like this. And instead of
set default, it will be used a default. And
make sure we use that everywhere as well.
So if we come back, the idea here is that
if we select to use the default shipping address,
then all of this will be hidden. And that's
based on a toggle. So if you toggle this,
all of this will hide or show, which we'll
just do with jQuery. And we can also come
back into the form and make sure that this
country field has required equal false as
well, in the case that you use a default address,
then we can come back here and basically do
the exact same thing for the billing address.
So what I'm going to do is also make sure
these labels are correct. So let's just grab
the same billing address. So same billing
address. And this should actually be same
shipping address. And social these, then we
have set default shipping. So I'll just paste
that one here. And this is also going to be
a Boolean field. And then the last one here
is use default shipping. And we can get rid
of that save info there. And all of these
fields that we used for the shipping form,
we can come here and paste them all again,
and just call all of these, the billing equivalent.
So like this, and we can actually just cut
these three out and move them below. So like
this. And just like we'll have set default
shipping and use default shipping, we're going
to have the exact same thing for the billing
equivalent. So this will be set default billing
and set default or use default billing. So
just like this, and then we can come back
here, go to the billing address. And I'm just
going to copy all of those inputs that we
just created here into the billing address
form. Okay, there we go. So now we have the
billing address, exact same thing as the shipping
address. So we have address one, and we have
address two. Then we have billing country,
and we have Billings up. And instead of having
two checkboxes here, too. One of them is this
billing address is the same as my shipping
address, we wouldn't have that again. So all
we have here is set default billing. And then
we'll handle use default billing as well.
So we can actually just copy this here. And
right before the HR. And we can actually just
get rid of that one there. Then instead of
use default shipping, this would be used default
billing. And we can just do the same thing
for over here. And add it in like that. And
there we go. So now we have the billing address
form, save as default billing address and
use default billing address. And now, we just
want to make sure that these checkboxes are
only being displayed if we actually have a
default billing address or default shipping
address. So let's go here into the view. And
I'm going to get rid of all of that there.
And let's just go here into the get request.
And we'll actually need to import the address
which we do over there. And so here, we're
going to need to get some query sets. So run
off to the context, we can update the context,
if we have a default shipping address. So
what we can do is, say, the shipping address,
query set equals to the address, where we
will filter it based on the current user.
And let's just put this on a new line, then
we will say that the address type is going
to be billing or rather shipping in this case.
And we're going to say that default equals
to true so that we get the default address.
And then we can just say, if shipping address
query set exists, then we will say context
dot update. And here we'll say default shipping
address is that shipping address, first item,
and then we can copy this. And we'll do the
exact same thing for the billing address.
So let's just rename this billing address
and change this to be, then if that query
set exists, we will set the default billing
address is equal to billing address query
set of zero, cool, then we can come in here.
And for this one for the billing address,
we can just say if, and it's just going to
get that value there. So if default billing
address is being passed into the context,
then we will actually render this. And here,
we can just get rid of that and actually output
the default address. so here we can say, default
billing address, dot address. And then we
can say, truncate characters to let's say,
10. And then we can copy that, and come back
up here for the shipping address. And say,
if us, or if there's a default shipping address,
then we will output it like that. And do the
exact same thing over here. So if default
shipping address, then we'll say endif. Come
back. And let's just see name request is not
defined. So if we go back here, this is self
dot request dot user, and just add it in there.
Okay. And refresh this. Cool. So now those
checkboxes will only output if we actually
have a default. And now we need to work on
the logic of what actually happens when we
submit in the post request. So let's just
come back down here. And we can actually close
some of these files off. So the logic here
is first to check if we are using the default
shipping address. So that means we're going
to get the value from the cleaned data in
the form. If that value is true, then we will
use the default address. If it's false, then
that means that we were expected to enter
some information in the form. So let's just
come here and say use default shipping equals
two. And we'll just copy all of that there
and grab that value from the clean data. So
if your connection is going to hear if that
value is true, then I'm going to say print
using the default shipping address. And just
like we did over here, I'm going to copy that
query set and paste that all over here. And
I'm just going to call it D Address query
set for short. So what we want to do is first
check if this user actually has a default
shipping address, because if they don't, then
we're going to need to redirect back and display
some sort of message. So we'll just say, if
it exists, then also the shipping address
equals to that address query, set the first
value inside it. And then we can say else,
messages, dot info. And we'll pass self dot
request and say, no default shipping address
available. And we can just go and copy one
of these redirects here, back to the checkout
page. So just like this, so we're storing
it in this shipping address variable, which
we will either get from this condition, and
then we can just go down and say else, then
we can just say print user is entering a new
shipping address. And we'll do the exact same
thing where we assign this variable to be
the address over here, which is going to be
received or created in this exact same way
that we have been doing previously. So I'm
just going to tab all of that inside. And
we'll just make sure we label everything appropriately.
So let's actually just go back into the form.
And we'll say that the shipping address equals
to that shipping address to equals to this.
And then we have shipping country equals to
that value. And we have shipping sip equals
to that, then the payment option, I'm just
going to cut and paste over there, because
we don't need that for now. So this is the
shipping address, which I'm going to rename,
I'm going to change this to be shipping. And
then we will pass in all of these values.
And just make sure we save the shipping address
thing. And then we can say order dot shipping
address equals to that. And what we're going
to do is do it outside of the else statement.
So that either way, we are storing it as the
shipping address received from here, or as
the new one over here. And I'll actually just
change this label to be shipping address one,
so we don't get any kind of conflicts with
variable names. Cool. So now we are saving
the shipping address onto the order. And at
this point, what we want to do is check if
we are setting this current shipping address
that we just created to be the new default.
So what I'm going to do is say set default
shipping equals to, and we will just copy
all of that there and get the value from that
form and just say if set default shipping
is true, then we just want to take that shipping
address. And we're just going to say dot default
equals true. And then just say not safe. So
now we've saved it as a default shipping address
so that next time, we will be able to filter
for it and display that to the user. And basically
all of this logic that we just did over here,
for the shipping address, this is what we
want to do. Well, everything from here, this
is what we want to do for the billing address
as well. But inside here in the URL statement,
if we are creating a new address, we're going
to want to validate these values over here
because we've gone here in the form and specify
that they are not required. And that could
lead to some issues where users could submit
empty strings. And we obviously don't want
that. So we can just come up here above the
class. And just to find a method that can
help us with this. So I'll just say this is,
let's say, is valid form. And we'll just say
that it takes in a list of values. And we
can say, for field in values, then we can
check if that field is equal to an empty string.
And above this for loop, we could have a total
value which is valid and say that it initially
is valid. But the moment we get an empty string,
we set it to be invalid. So we'll just say
if field equals an empty string, then we will
say valid equals to false. And then here to
say return valid. And then here we can just
take that is valid form. And we'll come here
Right above the values here or just after
we receive it, but below, and just above the
shipping address where we created. So we'll
say, if is valid form. And here, we'll just
pass in a list of values. So the ones that
are required, which would be the shipping
address, one, the shipping country and the
shipping, zip. So if all of those values are
valid, then we can just tab that in. So to
do all of that logic, and otherwise, we can
then just say, messages dot info of self dot
request. And we'll just say, Please fill in
the required shipping address fields. And
then we can just take all of that and put
that inside the if statement as well. So just
tablets in. And there we go, then what I'm
going to do is basically copy all of this.
And we can then can be lowered. And I'll just
paste it all there. And do the exact same
thing for us default billing. So we'll say
if use default billing is true, then we will
say using the default billing address, and
we will filter for billing addresses. If the
address exists, then we will create a billing
address variable, which is the first item
in the query set, or say, no default billing
address is available otherwise. And here we'll
say user is entering a new billing address.
And we'll just change the values inside here.
And then we can just take all of these and
make sure that we pass them into the new address.
So I'll just paste them all here. And make
sure that this is a billing type address.
And will you all label it as well. And pass
in all of the values into the is valid form
check, then we can say order dot billing address
equals to that billing address and save it.
And actually, we'll need to save it on this
condition as well. So let's just add it over
there. And then we'll do the same thing that
we did for the shipping address over here
in this condition as well. There we go. So
now let's just come back down. And we'll do
the same thing here use default billing, or
set default billing. So just added in there.
So if that value is true, then we'll say that
the billing address default is equal to true.
Also, please fill in the required billing
address fields. And then there's just one
more thing that we need to add, which is if
we are using the same billing address as shipping
address, so that's going to be something that
we need to check here at the beginning. So
over here, so we can just come and grab that
value. So same billing address equals to and
just copy all of this. So what we should actually
do first is check if that value is true. So
we'll say if same billing address, then what
I'm going to do is set the billing address
equal to the shipping address, but I'm going
to clone it. So I'm going to say that the
primary key equals none. And then we can say
that save so that it creates a new address.
And then we can say that the billing address
dot address type equals to a billing address.
And then we will say that save and then save
it on to the order. So if this condition is
true, we will do all of that. Otherwise, we
check if we're using the default billing address.
And otherwise, as the last condition, we're
assuming that the user is entering form data.
So after this last l statement, we get the
payment option and do the exact same thing,
as usual. So if we check here, the server
is still running. So we can come back here
and refresh this. And let's just also go back
and go to addresses. So we don't have any
right now. So let's enter some information.
And I'm going to say Save as default. Then
we can enter some other information in here.
And I'm going to say Save as default as well.
And we'll say stripe, continue to checkout
and if we come back in refresh this. Now we
have two default addresses. One is billing.
One is shipping, caught. Now let's go back.
And I'm just refreshing this. And what I'm
going to do is say, use default shipping address,
and we're not getting it displayed there.
Let's just see why that is. So street address
is actually the field we need to output. So
let's just come here and say this is street
address, then we can copy that and bring it
to the billing address as well. So if we refresh
this, now we have that default street address
showing as an indication. So if we select
both of those, and then select stripe, and
continue, that went through. So let's also
go back here to the order. And we'll just
come here and say that there is no relationship
to a shipping and billing address. And that's
your reference code is required. So what I'm
going to do is go back here to the model,
so we can change that. And this is on the
order. And here I'll just add, blank and null
or true for this field. And then we can just
make migrations, and then migrate, and then
run the server. So let's come back and refresh
this, click Continue. Okay, so now we don't
have a shipping or billing address, so we
can test this again. So let's go back. And
so we're using default shipping using default
billing, click Continue. Go back, refresh
this. And there we go. So now we have the
shipping address and the billing address being
used. And lastly, it's let's go and test another
case. So just refresh there. And let's go
and delete those addresses as well. So just
delete those. And what we're going to do is
say, billing address is the same as my shipping
address. So let's just add information there.
And select stripe, continue. OK, let's come
back and refresh this. So now we have billing,
and we have shipping, exact same information.
And if we go back and go to the order, then
it's linking that same one as well. So this
seems to be working so far, what we can do
now is just add in a little bit of jQuery
to say that when we select the use default
address, that it then toggles this display.
So let's go back here, and we can go into
check out and just come all the way to the
bottom. And let's also open up based on HTML
and just see here that we have these scripts
being included. So what are we going to do
is add another block here, and we can just
call this the extra scripts. And then we can
say, END block, extra scripts, then we can
copy that entire block there. And right here
off the content, we'll add in our new script
over here. So let's just open up a script
tag. And if we just take a look here at the
classes we've added, so we have your high
double shipping form, which I should actually
call Hannibal billing form seeing as this
is for the billing address. And then we have
the same thing here, which is high level shipping
form. So I'm going to copy both of these two.
And then here, we can just create some variables,
then we're just going to use jQuery and access
it with those classes. So just paste those
values there. And then we're also going to
need the checkboxes. So the first one being
this one here, so having the name of use default
shipping and an idea of use default shipping,
and the other one is the shipping one or billing
one. So here we'll say variable. Use default
shipping equals two, we can just say document,
dot query selector. And we can just open up
the input tag and say where the name is equal
to use default shipping. And then this one
will be use default billing and change the
name in there. And all we need to do here
is just say, if use default shipping is changed,
which we can handle With an event listener,
so we can just say add event listener, and
listen for the change event, then we can create
a function as a callback. And we'll just say
if this dot checked, which is a property on
the checkbox, HTML tag. So if it is checked,
then we're going to say hi, double shipping
form dot hide, which is that jQuery method.
And then we can say, otherwise, high level
shipping form dot show. And we can call these
methods because we're accessing these variables
with the jQuery selector. So I can just copy
this entire script tag there. And we'll say
that this is for the use default billing,
and then say, Hi, double billing form, dot
hide or show. Now if we come back and refresh
this, we'll just go back into the admin and
let's just go to those addresses. And then
we can just say that they were default. And
this one is also default, refresh this. So
if I select use default, you can see a toggle
that form. And that way, we at least, get
this indication that we don't need to fill
in any of the other form fields, if we do
select this. And this is then a lot better
than just leaving it open. So at least providing
some information to the user. Click Continue.
And it takes you to this page where we've
seen the payment process does work. So that's
all we wanted to handle in this one, which
was just improving this checkout process of
adding a billing address and a shipping address.
So now we can at least control that information
much better and stored more accurately. And
also provide a better way of our users actually
entering that information by providing this
default option. And also, the concept of billing
address is the same as my shipping address,
then we could actually do the exact same thing
for that toggle. So if you toggle this one,
it could either pre populate this form or
cause a drop down where it hides or shows
it. But now that you've seen how we can do
it with this toggle example, you can try and
implement this one yourself. So we're just
going to leave it at this. Now before getting
started, I just want to point out that we
are not going to be teaching how to store
credit card information ourselves that's not
secure. And it's not a good way to do it,
we're either going to be using stripe to store
that information as they are the payment processor.
And that's what they're built to do. So this
tutorial is going to focus on retrieving that
information from stripe and not storing it
ourselves. Okay, so in this one, we're going
to be adding functionality that allows a user
to similar to the last video where you could
use a default billing address. Now we're allowing
you to have a default payment method, particularly
with stripe, so basically a default card that
you can use in the rest of your purchases.
So you don't have to keep on adding that card
number every time you want to make a payment,
you can just select that card. And we've already
gone and implemented this functionality. So
the format of this video is going to be a
little bit different in that we're not going
to be building it in this video rather just
walking through the functionality that has
been added already. And this is just because
it's not actually a lot of code. And it's
not a lot of functionality. The concept is
pretty much the exact same as in the previous
video where we were just allowing a user to
click a checkbox, which would then basically
show the user what they're allowed to see
in the form, which would either be entering
a new billing address or selecting the current
one that they have the exact same concept
as that. So if you haven't watched the previous
video, then I suggest rather go ahead and
watch that video as that video contains basically
the logic that was used to fill in this functionality
in this video. But basically, the concept
is that if I add something to cart, and just
proceed to checkout, then let's just use a
default billing address and default shipping
address select stripe. And the idea is basically
that we have this checkbox here that I can
select and it says use default card. And then
we have the first 12 digits that are just
stars because you don't know what they are.
And then it gives you an indication of what
that card is. So the last four digits and
then the expiration date. And basically like
this, you can either select to use this default
card and pay with this because this is linked
to your profile. Or you can go and add a new
card over here as usual. And you can either
save this for future purposes or not. So it's
the exact same concept as the previous video
and let's just go and walk through the code
that was added to do this. So We'll start
off in our models. And basically, for us to
show the user any card that they have used
before in a purchase. That would mean that
we have to store some of that information
somehow. So what we've done is added a user
profile model, which is basically linked to
a user with a one to one field. So every user
has their own user profile. And we use the
post save signal to create that user profile,
the moment that the user is created. So we
just specify the sender as that auth user
model. And we say if that instance, so the
user, if the user is created, then we just
call user profile on objects dot create and
just pass in the user as the only required
argument, which basically creates that users
user profile. And by default, you're not going
to have a stripe customer ID and you're not
going to have one click purchasing activated.
This one click purchasing is more of a concept
than actual functionality right now. So that's
something that we could add in future videos.
But basically, you have these two fields as
kind of like settings on the user. And they
can then go and configure this later on. So
the stripe customer ID will get populated
if they decide to save their customer information
when they check out. And that being, if they
were to say save for future purchases, and
enter their card information here, then we
need to store that information. So what we
do is here in the view, we'll just go all
the way to the top of this payment view. So
let's just look at the POST method first.
Basically, what's happening is, we're now
receiving the token and some extra information
from the form, which is firstly, the Save
value, which is basically whether or not we
should save the current card that the user
just inputted into the form. And then use
default means use the default card. So that's
the only information we're getting from our
post request. If we are saving it, then all
we do is assign it to the user. So we first
check if there is a stripe customer ID associated
on that user profile. If there isn't one,
then that means that this is the first time
they're saving information. So what we do
is we create the stripe customer. And we pass
in the source as the card that they just put
in and just create that user profile, where
we're assigning the stripe customer ID as
the ID of this API call over here. And then
we can also just set one click purchasing
equal to true for future references, save
the user profile. And otherwise, if the user
profile does exist already, then all we're
doing is creating a source. So you can call
stripe dot customer dot create source, which
only takes in the customer ID and the source.
So that will basically add a new source onto
the customer. And that's all the functionality
is for whether or not we want to save information,
then we go on to actually processing the charge.
So if we're using the default card on the
user's profile, then we simply just have to
pass in the customer into the stripe dot charge
create API call. Whereas if we're not using
the default card, then we have to pass in
the source that we want to charge. And basically,
you could view this as one is for users that
have kind of like a profile, and one is for
users that are making sort of like an anonymous
purchase. So for one, you're basically allowing
us to retrieve your past credit card information,
and the other you're not. So you have to enter
that every single time. And that's the only
change that's been made. In charging the user,
basically just one of these two methods has
to occur. And everything after that is exactly
the same. We create the payment and perform
the rest of the billing logic here. But this
is just for the POST method. If we take a
look here at the get method. Here, what we're
doing is we're grabbing the user profile,
and we're checking if one click purchasing
is activated. And if it is, then what we do
is we fetch the users cards, which is listed
on their stripe customer. So what we do is
just called stripe customer dot list sources.
And then here you just pass in the arguments,
which are the stripe customer ID, the limit
of how many results you want to get back,
which is set to three and then the type of
object that you want to filter for, because
you get many different sources that stripe
actually handles. So we're only looking for
cards as the specific object. So we just pass
an object as card. And now we'll have a list
of cards, which we can either iterate through
or we can just grab the first one, which is
what we're doing here. So we're checking if
the list of that card is greater than zero,
then we just update the context to have a
card. And then that card we output here in
our HTML by just using some template syntax
here. So we just say if there's a card, we
are put just another div which has a checkbox
in it. And inside of here you can see we are
putting, for example the last four which are
the last four digits On the card, the expiration
month, the expiration year. So we are put
all of that if there is a card. And then we've
just restructured the template similar to
in the last video, we now we just added some
JavaScript down here that based on the input,
that is a checkbox, if you do select it, then
it will hide the one form and show the other
form, and vice versa. So basically, what we
can do is we can log out, and we will sign
up with a new user. Okay, cool, we can now
go and add something to the cart, proceed
to checkout. And let's just enter some information,
select stripe continue to check out. There
we go. Now we can see that we aren't getting
that checkbox because we don't have any cards
at the moment. And let's go and open up an
incognito window just so we can go into the
admin. We can go to user profiles, go to that
new user. And there we go. So no stripe customer
ID, and one click purchasing not active yet.
Now let's just go back here. And what I'll
do is input some credit card information,
click Save for future purchases, and click
Submit. Cool. And so now the order was successful.
And if we check the admin, the customer ID
is now there, one click purchasing is now
there. So if we try and add something again,
and let's just go use default, and select
stripe continue to check out. And now we have
the option to use a default card so we can
select that submit the payment and order was
successful. And so that's all we wanted to
show in this video, which was basically just
taking the same logic from the previous video
of how you can save a default address in the
same way by storing a default payment method,
which in this case is in the form of a credit
card. And the best thing about it is that
we aren't actually storing that information
ourselves. We're always fetching that from
stripe, which makes it much better. So if
you enjoyed this video, then leave a comment
down below. Let us know what you thought.
Otherwise, thanks for watching. Don't forget
to subscribe and we'll see you in the next
one.